Ich bin am Start, Leute. Hat ein bisschen länger gedauert. Fast 11 Kilometer ge... Naja, na. Abgerundet eher 10 Kilometer ge... geflitzt.
Und ich bin erst um 8 Uhr 30 oder so losgelaufen. Dementsprechend war ich erst 9 Uhr 35 oder sowas wieder daheim.
Und... also war... na gut. Ich mein, irgendwann muss ich auch mal ausschlafen, ja.
Und ausschlafen heißt bei manchen ja bis 12 Uhr pennen. Bei mir heißt ausschlafen bis 8.
Also insofern... oder nicht immer bis 8. Bis 7 Uhr 50 oder so ist bei mir ausschlafen.
Ich mein, ihr müsst euch nicht wundern, warum ich immer boomermüde boomerbett um 22 Uhr bis... oder 23 Uhr bin.
Ich steh halt sonst 7 Uhr 30 oder so. 7 Uhr 30... 7 Uhr bis...
7 Uhr 30 normalerweise auf. Und sonntags halt auch mal 7 Uhr 45.
Aber ihr wisst ja, im Alter braucht man eh weniger Schlaf. Nicht so wild.
Mein Handy macht komische Geräusche.
So.
Also. Chat hier.
Ich muss grad meinen Vorschau-Rechner noch anmachen. Ich seh gar nix, außer hier den Chat im Fullscreen.
Was macht eigentlich... gerade wo ich das Emote seh...
Und nicht...
Es interessiert ja so Promizeuch und so überhaupt nicht.
Aber was... macht...
Eigentlich...
Was macht eigentlich der Wendler?
Nicht, dass es mich wirklich großartig interessieren würde, aber...
Jetzt, wo ich das Emote grad sehe...
Was treibt der eigentlich?
Näääh, der ist nicht Dead Cornell...
Der... der macht komische Sachen und...
War der nicht bei Xavier Naidoo, was, äh, keine Ahnung, Flat Earth und alles unterirdische Bunker, wo Kinder entführt werden und hast du nicht...
Die erzählen doch den weird, weird champigsten Kram.
War der da nicht auch dabei irgendwie?
Ah, Vorschau-Rechner anmachen.
Nice. Gut.
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Büschnis Mount Everest-Mails gucken, ob da irgendwas Wichtiges dabei ist, was ich übersehen hab.
Ähm, Key Shops, China-Chinesen-Hardware, Key Shops, Zeug, von dem ich noch nie was gehört hab.
Ey, gar nicht so übel.
Und, World of Warships. Alter, wie oft wollen die noch schreiben?
So.
So, gleich da ist vorbei. Ich war gleich da. Also, ich bin, ich bin gleich da.
Wenn wir grad dabei sind, ich mach mal die VM an und mach mal Package-Updates.
Arch, by the way, muss immer up-to-date sein.
Massive, Bleeding Edge, 5-Head, Updated, Top-Aktuell, Blazingly-Fast-Software.
Ich will's gar nicht so genau wissen.
Um nicht zu sagen, es ist mir...
Ups. Irgendwie hat das mein Cursor nicht richtig gecaptured.
Updates, Shader, ich, Leute, die Updates sind...
Updaten immer Sachen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist, warum ich das überlebe.
Was ist Shader C?
Collection of Tools, Libraries and Tests for Shader Compilation.
Okay, warum hab ich das installiert? Für was?
Kann ich das deinstallieren? Und wenn...
Nein, kann nicht, weil...
Lip Placebo war ja das. Okay.
Was ist Lip Placebo?
Reuseable GPU, Accelerated Video, Dings.
Okay.
Und warum brauch ich das?
Das brauch ich, weil...
VLC!
Aha!
VLC braucht es, ja.
Okay, dann lassen wir's installiert.
VLC ist wichtig.
Oh, Reboot.
Schätke, was meint ihr?
Bevor wir anfangen, uns Zeug anzugucken.
Meint ihr, ich pack das bis Ende des Jahres...
unter einer Stunde 10 Kilometer?
Ich mein, ich hab noch ein bisschen Energie, so ist das nicht.
Also, ich bin den letzten Kilometer heute mit 5.10 gerannt.
Da bin ich ganz schön außer Puste, aber trotzdem, ja.
Das heißt, ich denke, es ist theoretisch möglich, noch ein bisschen schneller zu rennen.
Und ich hab ja noch einen Monat Zeit, eineinhalb Monate Zeit bis Ende des Jahres.
Meint ihr, ich kann das auf die Reihe kriegen, ich kann das packen?
Also, eine Stunde für 10 Kilometer bis Ende des Jahres?
Also, das wird auf jeden Fall knapp.
Okay.
Moment, wollen wir mal gucken, ob ich unter 90 Kilo habe?
Moment, das muss ich kurz ausprobieren.
Ich muss mal kurz rüber mich schnell wiegen.
Zack, ich wiege mich mal schnell.
Gucken, ob ich, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Chat, es ist soweit.
Ich muss in Foto wachen.
Ich habe es geschafft.
So.
Die Waage hat mich massive jebaited.
Ich bin gerade rübergegangen, habe mich draufgestellt.
Da hatte ich noch Socken an und die Unterhose, ja.
Da hatte ich glatt 90 Kilo auf meiner Waage.
Habe ich mir gedacht, okay.
Du gehst jetzt rüber, holst das Handy zum Waage fotografieren.
Habe ich die Socken und die Unterhose ausgezogen.
Habe mich wieder auf die Waage gestellt.
90,2.
Wie kann ich denn, bitteschön, ohne Unterhose und Socken auf einmal mehr wiegen als vorher?
Ich glaube, die Waage ist nicht so hundertprozentig accurate.
Es ist halt, das Handy, ne, ne, ne, das Handy, ich bin ja nicht blöd.
Das Handy habe ich später in die Hand genommen.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht das Handy.
Ich stelle es nicht drauf und danach, wenn die gemessen hat, wird es fotografiert.
Aber die hat mich massive, massive jebaited.
Ich habe eine Xiaomi Mi Scale 2, nicht Home Assistant, so ein Ding.
Und die ist schon halbwegs genau, aber anscheinend schwankt es etwas.
Ja, das ist ja doof.
Na gut.
Dann halt nicht.
Also, soll mir recht sein, ja.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr viel bis unter 90 Kilo.
Kam der BF, was für, achso.
Es ist ja nicht Battlefield, es ist Black Friday.
Ne, ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was ich da shoppen soll.
Da ist doch eh immer der gleiche Müll.
1000 Schwachsinnige.
1000 Schwachsinnige Sachen, die keiner braucht.
Amazon eigene Geräte, die sind immer ganz gut, wenn man denn welche braucht.
Aber ich brauche auch nicht das 100. Fire Tablet.
Und ansonsten ab und zu mal eine SSD oder sowas kann man da ganz gut abgreifen.
Oh, ne, ne, ne.
Ich habe, Leute, ich habe so keinen Bock auf MB3.
Ich finde ja schon komplett kreativ bankrott alles seit dem 2019er Reboot von Modern Warfare.
Das war aber wenigstens noch ganz, ganz gut gemacht.
Du hast gemerkt, dass da Leute dran gearbeitet haben, die irgendwie was, ja, noch versucht haben, was auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Ich finde, bei MB2 hat man das schon deutlich weniger gemerkt.
Und MB3 ist ja nun wirklich voll für den Arsch.
Ich werde es nicht kaufen, ich werde es nicht spielen, ich werde es nicht streamen, ich werde meine Meinung nicht zu sagen.
Also, das sage ich jetzt, kann sich nächste Woche schon wieder ändern, ihr kennt mich.
Und nachdem mich Warzone auch nicht so großartig interessiert, eigentlich keinen Bock.
Überhaupt keinen Bock auf MB3.
Ich habe aber ein bisschen das Ganze mitverfolgt und MB3 kommt allgemein auch genauso beschissen an, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Das ist noch ein Röhrenfernseher.
Moment, der macht Videos wieder.
Das ist der da noch, die MB2.
Ja, der die MB2 Nuke-Videos immer gebracht hat, genau.
Nuke-Challenge, Nuke-Challenge und so.
Da haben wir...
Ja, aber es interessiert mich nicht.
Es interessiert mich so wenig, dass ich mir, obwohl ich die Videos von ihm gerne geguckt habe, dass ich nicht mal das Video dazu angucken will.
Gar kein Bock.
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Das sind wir lieber.
Placingly fast written in rust.
Das hat Chatge, ich muss ja mal sagen, der Stream gestern hat echt Bock gemacht.
Auch wenn ich nichts gecheckt habe am Ende mehr.
Aber man hat echt was gelernt.
Ah ja, und ich habe unter anderem gelernt, ich werde Rust wahrscheinlich nicht für irgendwelche Daily-Projekte nehmen, wo es schnell gehen muss.
Weil wenn eine Sache nicht ist, also wenn eine Sache Rust nicht ist, dann ist es schnell zu schreiben.
Es ist vielleicht schnell, wenn es geschrieben ist und ausgeführt wird.
Aber die Software zu erstellen ist Rust absolut das Gegenteil von Placingly fast.
Ja, die ganzen krassen Krustentiere sagen jetzt natürlich wieder, Max,
das liegt nur an dir.
Das kann schon sein.
Irgendwo liegt es natürlich immer an dem, der es programmiert.
Aber wenn man das mal vergleicht, wie super weirdchampig das alles aussieht.
Wie tausend Awaits, Unwrap, Get, Read Only, Unwrap, Unwrap, Await.
Ne, da kriegst du Anfälle.
So, die VM hat neu gestartet.
Wir brauchen die VM jetzt gar nicht.
Ich lasse aber trotzdem mal an.
Es schadet.
Es schadet auf jeden Fall nix.
Moin, Darkseid.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal gucken, was trendet denn auf Shithub die Woche?
Google hat gerad...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, schreck mich nicht so.
Was ist das?
Hetzner for Gamers.
Was haben die denn da am Start?
Kannst du da als Minecraft-Server uns heucheln?
With our servers we have full control over your gaming environment.
Ah ja, gut.
Ich meine, ich gehe mal davon aus, es ist komisch, dass die...
Also, was ich jetzt schon erlebt habe, ist der umgedrehte Fall, dass irgendein Game-Server-Hoster irgendwann auch mehr anbietet.
Also so Nitrado oder sowas, falls das überhaupt noch jemand benutzt.
Die haben ja erst mit Game-Server angefangen und kannst du jetzt auch noch mehr mieten.
Aber Hetzner macht es jetzt umgedreht oder...
Ja, wobei, das hat doch mit Game-Server nix zu tun.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Server.
Aber du kannst wahrscheinlich...
Du kannst wahrscheinlich einfach...
Über das Management-Panel da jetzt Minecraft draufhauen, ohne dass du dich mit Linux auskennen musst oder...
Also ich meine, was ist der Vorteil davon?
So ein ganz nackiger Server, oder?
Cloud Pricing.
Das hat doch mit Gaming-Sachen nix zu tun.
Das ist ein nackiger Cloud-Server.
Okay, Hetzner sponsert die...
Irgendein League of Legends-Ding?
Was mit ihren Servern?
Nein.
Gar nix zu tun hat?
Ja, guck mal.
Hä, okay.
Du kannst...
Ja, du musst sogar User und so alles selbst adden.
Hä, das verstehe ich.
Das hat doch mit Game-Server, also mit fertigen Game-Servern gar nix zu tun.
Das sind stinknormale Cloud-Server, wo du dann halt beispielsweise Minecraft drauf installierst.
Das kann ich schon seit Jahren damit machen.
Das ist doch überhaupt nix Neues.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur ein Marketing-Versuch für alle, die noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen sind.
Dass man ja auch sich einfach einen Minecraft-Server selbst installieren kann und nicht bei irgendeinem Minecraft-Server-Hoster das machen muss, das denen nochmal zu erklären, dass das auch geht.
Ja.
Im Prinzip ist es genau das gleiche wie vorher.
Das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Aber ich finde das interessant, dass Hetzner jetzt so Richtung Online-Promotion...
Gaming und Online-Marketing-Sachen geht.
Also ich weiß noch, als ich mit denen telefoniert habe, 2000...
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Wann habe ich die erste Hetzner-Sache damals gemacht?
Da hatten die noch ganz wenig Erfahrung mit Online-Sachen.
Das hat gerade erst angefangen.
Aber die haben es richtig gemacht.
Die haben es richtig gemacht.
Du musst heutzutage in die Richtung gehen.
Und auch die Sponsorings, die sie da haben beim Bauer...
Teilweise...
Oder bei...
Es gibt ja noch mehr.
Ich glaube, das ist genau das Richtige für die.
Weil dort gucken technikinteressierte Leute, die dann sagen, ach ja gut, ich bräuchte mal einen Server.
Wo geht man hin?
Ah ja, guck mal, wie wäre es mit Hetzner?
Da ist es einfach wichtig, dass man bekannt ist.
So, und das hier ist jetzt eher so eine Sache mit...
Man nimmt das, was man schon hat und erklärt halt den Leuten, ey, guck mal, auch wenn ihr da bisher noch nicht dran gedacht habt,
ihr könnt auch sowas nehmen und euch selbst Minecraft drauf installieren.
Obwohl das im Prinzip schon...
Ähm...
Schon immer geht.
Das gibt es garantiert schon.
Minecraft-Installer und sowas.
Und mich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn die im Control-Panel bei Hetzner demnächst irgendwie so Standard-Game-Server anbieten würden.
Das muss man nämlich sagen, das Web-Interface von Hetzner, also zumindest für Hetzner Cloud, ist echt gut.
Das ist minimalistisch.
Man muss ja auch mal ehrlich sagen, die Hetzner Cloud an sich von Features her können die jetzt ja nicht viel.
Die haben 4Ms, die haben Storage und die haben Load Balancer.
Das war es im Endeffekt.
Also das ist ja mal, würde ich sagen, das ist ja das absolute Minimum, das man sich irgendwie vielleicht Cloud nennen darf.
Aber das Zeug funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Was sie haben funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Und es ist preislich super.
Und das, was integriert ist, also das, was sie haben...
...ist auch super integriert in das Web-Interface und geht super schnell.
Ich meine ernsthaft, wenn ihr mal bei Google Cloud rumklickt, dort 4Ms, Storage, sonst was.
Das fühlt sich alles so unglaublich laggy an im Browser.
Und bei Hetzner flutscht das und ist blazingly fast.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die written in Rust sind.
Aber das fühlt sich schon deutlich angenehmer an.
Aber natürlich ist es auch unfair, das zu vergleichen.
Weil wenn du dir anguckst, was du beispielsweise bei Google in der Cloud für 4Ms...
...features hast, versus was du bei Hetzner hast.
Das ist halt, Hetzner hat halt so 3% von dem, was Google hat.
Dafür preislich deutlich attraktiver bei den Sachen als Google.
Bei Google bezahlst du für eine fette 4M durchaus mal 1000 Euro im Monat.
Bei Hetzner kostet das 300.
Und bei Hetzner kriegst du auch richtig fette Hardware-Kisten mit 32 Kern Ryzen-CPU, 64...
...oder 128 GB RAM, 64 TB NVMe SSD für 500, 600 Euro im Monat.
Und bei Google gibt es das schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht.
Es ist nicht Sponsor-Stream.
Ich müsste mit denen mal wieder irgendwas vereinbaren.
Ich hätte echt Bock, mal wieder irgendwas anzupreisen von Hetzner.
Wir haben schon eine Weile nichts mehr gemacht.
Ich habe auch noch keine guten Ideen gehabt mehr.
Und jetzt mit...
Und jetzt mit der neuen Arbeit und so habe ich ja eh weniger gestreamt.
Aber ich glaube, es wäre mal wieder an der Zeit, eine Runde Hetzner-Promotion zu machen.
Ich meine, ich promote die ja indirekt oftmals auch, ohne dass ich dafür Geld kriege.
Einfach, weil ich das Zeug nicht schlecht finde.
Ja, das wäre natürlich nice.
Das würde bestimmt viele überzeugen.
Die haben ja schon so ein paar One-Click-Installer für WordPress und sowas.
Warum nicht auch für Minecraft anbieten?
Ich meine, ehrlich.
Minecraft dürfte wahrscheinlich der Hauptantrieb für Game-Server heutzutage sein.
Weil in was mieten sich Leute denn heutzutage Server?
CS wie früher?
Nö.
CS-Server hat doch heute keiner mehr, wirklich.
Battlefield-Server gibt es nicht mehr.
Cod-Server gibt es auch keine.
Vielleicht Rust oder sowas.
Rust vielleicht?
Weiß nicht, ob das noch angesagt ist.
GTA?
Ja, vielleicht.
GTA, Rust und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber hauptsächlich, das meiste vermutlich, würde ich jetzt einfach mal raten,
vielleicht auch der ein oder andere, aber die meisten Server, die so gemietet werden,
für Gaming heutzutage, so Community-Gaming-mäßig,
sind wahrscheinlich ernsthaft Minecraft-Server.
Würde ich jetzt mal raten.
So, lass uns mal gucken, was auf Shithub trendet.
Draw a UI.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein neues Repo, das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Ja, es ist neu.
Alter!
14 Tage altes Repo.
Und einfach mal 10.000 Sterne, Alter!
Das ist ja fast so viel wie der Fiat Champ.
Nicht ganz, aber fast.
Was macht der Fiat Champ eigentlich mit Issues?
Ah, immer noch keine Fehler.
Sehr gut.
Was ist das?
Ja, das versuche ich gerade rauszubekommen.
Ah!
Man malt was und daraus,
erzeugt AI und TL-Draw dann HTML.
Also man malt quasi in Paint was
und das erzeugt dann,
das, was man in Paint gemalt hat,
also in diesem Paint-Verschnitt,
wird dann als HTML generated.
Ich zeige euch das hier.
Kann man das groß machen vielleicht?
Äh, naja.
Okay, und da macht AI jetzt eine Webseite draus.
Okay.
Nicht schlecht.
Ich frage mich,
inwieweit das in der Praxis wirklich brauchbar ist.
Du kannst dir vielleicht Inspiration holen.
Aber ich frage mich halt,
wie maintainable das ist,
was das da raushaut.
Aber man muss super schnell
quick and dirty was auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und kann ich richtig HTML
und CSS?
Ist das, glaube ich,
gar nicht verkehrt.
Auf jeden Fall coole Idee.
Okay, man braucht einen OpenAI-RPG.
Was kein Ding ist,
um es auszuprobieren,
weil man kann ja das kostenlose Kontingent benutzen.
Aber coole Sache.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die AI durchaus auch
Vue oder React-Apps
generaten kann mittlerweile
oder sogar Svelte-Apps.
Aber coole Idee.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nice.
Das ist, finde ich, ein gutes Beispiel,
wo AI einem auch mal ein bisschen Arbeit abnehmen kann.
Und, ähm,
sei es nur zu Inspirationszwecken.
So, okay, AI.
Lassen wir bleiben.
AI, AI.
Mona Space.
Okay, weitere, weitere.
Okay.
Ich bin ja immer ganz interested,
was neue Fonts angeht.
Ich benutze seit Jahren Hack als Font.
Aber ich gucke mir auch immer gern mal...
Okay.
Hä?
Alter.
Font.
Font-Fachsprache.
Ja?
Each one has a distinctive voice.
Äh, distinct voice.
Wie, wie, wie kann ein...
Ich mein, ich weiß...
Ich kann mir überdenken, was die mir sagen wollen, ja?
Die wollen sowas sagen wie...
Jedes hat so ein spezielles...
Ein spezielles Merkmal.
Aber...
Das ist ja fast wie wenn Weinkenner erzählen...
Oh, es ist, äh, so...
Frag mich nicht, wie Weinkenner das...
Erdig im Abgang, sowas, ja.
Oder die Whisky-Leute.
Man merkt das Eichenfass im, im...
Auf der Zunge, oder sowas.
Der Font.
Also, bei mir ist es der Font.
Kann man sich sicherlich drüber streiten.
Wobei ich die Varianten hier eigentlich ganz hübsch find.
Oh, nee.
Ich mag das nicht.
Jemand von euch...
Ligagers...
Ich kann das Wort nicht aussprechen.
Äh, Fan?
Also, das ist...
Hier sieht man das Wort nicht.
Hier sieht man das ganz gut.
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Ligaturen, oder so?
Ligaturen, ernsthaft?
Ligaturen.
Ligatures.
Ähm, mag das jemand von euch?
Also, man sieht hier, guck mal.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man ein Font hat.
Hier sieht man es ganz gut.
Wenn man ein Font hat, der Ligatures unterstützt.
Normalerweise sieht das so aus, ja.
Dass man da sagt, größer gleich.
Und wenn man ein Font hat, der Ligaturen kann.
Dann macht der aus zwei Zeichen.
Auch wenn die logisch gesehen immer noch zwei Zeichen sind im Code.
Macht der aber in eurem Editor da draus so ein...
Eher QuickMuffs Symbol.
Ich mag das nicht.
Ich weiß, da streiten sich die Geister dran.
Ob das jetzt gut oder nicht gut ist.
Das ist scheiße.
Das ist genial.
Okay, Chat, wo wir gerade dabei sind, da streiten sich die Geister dran.
Ja, die sind genial, das ist scheiße.
Wollen wir voten?
Okay, wir voten.
Ich mach mal nen Vote.
Moment, nee, nee.
Poll.
Ligatures.
Ja oder nein?
Ja, nein.
Machen wir was anderes.
Genial.
Mist.
Ab und zu.
Additional Votes per Kekse.
Ja, die Leute sollen mal ein bisschen Kekse ausgeben können.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Eine Minute.
Mist.
Ich tendiere auch zu Mist.
Also die meisten Leute denken auch, es ist Mist.
65% denken, es ist Mist.
22% denken, ab und zu kann man das mal verwenden.
Und ein paar denken, ganz toll, super genial.
So, so, so, so ungefähr.
Was?
Ne, ne, ne, das da wird zu feil.
Uah, uah, uah.
Twitch, Twitch, ihr geht!
Twitch benutzt auch Ligaturen.
Oh, das ist FFZ.
Nice Alfred.
Pog.
Jaja, das stimmt schon.
Es ging ja drum, ob man es mag oder nicht.
Ich mag es nicht.
Letztendlich ist der Source-Code der gleiche, der rauskommt.
Es macht doch heute kaum noch einen Unterschied.
FFZ kann 7-TV-E-Modes.
Nur ich glaube, Better Twitch-TV verwendet kaum noch einer.
Ja, mir hat der Stream gestern auch mega Bock gemacht.
Vor allem hat man mal was gelernt.
Rusttechnisch.
Ich bin geneigt, das mal auszuprobieren.
Mona Space.
Lass mal kurz checken, ob es das hier...
OTF Mona Space.
Super-innovativ-Super-Family.
Ne, Moment.
Ein innovativ-Super-Family of Fonz.
Lass mich mal kurz Mona Space installieren.
Ah, Moment.
Die Frage ist, ob mit Mona Space...
Lass das mal kurz im Terminal ausprobieren.
Wir testen das mal kurz im Terminal.
Config.
Westterm.
Font.
Fallback-Hacked-Vemoji.
Wie heißt denn dieser Kram jetzt überhaupt?
Wie heißt jetzt FC-List?
Crap.
Monaspace?
Alter, was?
Alter, wie viele...
What the...
Fuck, Alter.
Wie viele Monaspaces gibt es denn da bitte schon?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Okay, wir müssen das doch mal in einem anderen Editor mit grafischer Font-Auswahl machen.
Gab es nicht bei Gnome auch so ein Font-Select?
Monkaspace.
Okay, hier können wir uns das angucken.
Font.
Das ist, glaube ich, sogar...
Ist das JetBrains Mono oder Hack?
Das müsste eigentlich Hack sein.
Manchmal kann ich auch...
Also, dieses...
Dieses...
Wir suchen...
Es ist...
Also, manchmal...
Ist das echt pepega.
What the fuck?
Normalerweise findet man das hier doch da drüber.
Hier, Font.
Nee, es ist JetBrains Mono.
Also, normaler...
Normaler Font, den ich verwende...
Warum habe ich denn hier JetBrains Mono?
Normaler Font...
Erkennt man kaum Unterschied, ne?
Hatten die nicht mal einen Apply-Knopf?
Ach, hier neben kann man sich ja die Vorschau angucken.
So, Monaspace.
Guck mal, Hack und JetBrains Mono ist gar nicht so viel Unterschied.
Außer, dass Hack ein bisschen mehr Spacing hat zwischen den...
Zwischendingen.
So, und jetzt hier...
Monaspace.
Monaspace Argon.
Okay.
Krypton?
Oh, nee.
Das sieht kacke aus hier drin.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Guck mal, da hat sogar Ryder Probleme, das zu rendern, richtig.
Nee, das gefällt mir nicht.
Aber, mal so...
Das geht noch irgendwie klar.
Neon?
Oh, ja.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Das gefällt mir noch besser als Argon.
Wobei, kann man schon...
Radon?
Oh, nee.
Das ist für Comics-Sans-Lovers.
Das ist, ähm...
Xenon.
Hm.
Ich muss was sagen.
Ich glaube, Argon oder Neon.
Also, Neon oder Argon gefällt mir da am besten.
Ich tendiere zu Neon gerade.
Wobei ich bei Argon das J mir besser gefällt.
Na gut.
Wir bleiben aber bei JetBrains...
JetBrains Mono.
Ach, hier.
Na, das muss man wahrscheinlich aktivieren, erst.
Meinst du, wir sollen Ligaturen mal testen?
Vierer-Code kenne ich.
War nicht so meins.
Guck mal, kann man hier sogar...
Ist, glaube ich, ist das sogar eingebaut?
Sieht sehr ähnlich aus, auch.
Also, ich sehe da jetzt keine Ligaturen-enabled.
Was?
Also, JetBrains Mono kann es auf jeden Fall.
Was auch immer.
Wisst ihr was?
Zack.
Ich bleibe einfach bei dem Font, der hier eingestellt ist und gut ist.
Cascadia Mono.
Ich muss allgemein sagen, ich finde die Microsoft-Schrift, die Microsoft-Terminal-Schriften auch gar nicht übel.
Nicht so, dass ich sie unbedingt verwenden möchte, Cross-Plattform, aber ab und zu.
Ich bin dann immer angenehm überrascht.
Also, sowohl Cascadia als auch Lucida-Console sind eigentlich sehr nice Schriftarten.
Von Microsoft.
Denkst du, Gotter...
Gotter, Alter.
Docker läuft gut in einer VM.
Klar, warum nicht?
Docker läuft perfekt in VMs.
Um nicht zu sagen, ich verwende hier Docker eigentlich nur in VMs.
Warum sollte das nicht laufen?
Wunderbar.
Läuft das.
So, dann gucken wir mal weiter.
Ja.
Ich aninstalle das mal wieder.
Ach, komm, wir lassen es drauf.
Bei uns läuft ein Kubernetes-Cluster in einer VM.
Ja, und? Ist doch okay.
Selbst bei Google laufen die Kubernetes-Cluster in VMs.
Bietet sich auch oftmals an, einfach weil du dann auch die Node-Anzahl und alles sogar noch ein bisschen einfacher rauf und runter skalieren kannst, falls man das möchte.
Ich finde es gar nicht so verwerflich, Kubernetes-Cluster in einer VM laufen zu lassen.
Sogar VMware bietet ja mittlerweile ein Kubernetes-Interface für ihr VM-Zeug an.
Nennt sich Tanzu.
Deine Meinung zu ESX?
Ich habe wenig Erfahrung mit ESX.
Ich benutze das seit Jahren im Enterprise-Business-Umfeld.
Aber die Betonung liegt auf benutzt.
Nicht administriere oder großartig was mitmachen.
Ich benutze das.
Das funktioniert eigentlich grundsolide.
Es gibt selten Probleme, die ich damit benutze.
Es funzt, genau, es funzt.
Ja, VM in VM sieht schon wieder anders aus.
VM in VM kann schon echt Performance-Probleme geben.
Nested-Virtualisierung.
Aber nachdem Docker ja keine Virtualisierung ist, ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Container ist eh das größte G-Bait-Wort.
Im Prinzip sind ja, gibt es gar keine Container.
Ja, funktioniert halt.
Okay, was trendet sonst noch?
Proxmox, ESX, ich glaube, das hängt ganz von dem Anwendungsfall an.
Wenn man daheim irgendwas haben will oder nicht viel Kohle hat, die man VM, wobei ESX in der Basic-Variante, glaube ich, auch kostenlos ist.
Wenn man nicht viel Kohle hat, die man VMware hinterher schmeißen will, dann Proxmox.
Und das ist Xen-Server, das habe ich ewig nicht mehr im Einsatz gesehen.
Ne, wobei, es ist nicht Xen, das ist die Citrix-Geschichte, gell?
Das ist die, die, die, die Chitrix-Sache.
Okay.
Citrix ist doch Xen, oder?
Das sehe ich äußerst selten.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
AI juckt mich nicht.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, was?
Obama-Web-UI.
Ach ne, Lama-Web-UI.
Obama-Web-UI, man.
AI, AI, Tesla-Stells bringt mir nix.
Tesla-Stells.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
Rails-Trend...
Jawoll, Leute!
Ruby!
On Rails trendet, dass ich das noch erleben darf.
Gab's da eine neue Version, oder warum trendet das?
Warum bearbeitest du die Uhr ständig?
High IQ-Move.
Okay, 7.12 kam raus.
Ich muss ja sagen, eigentlich ist Ruby nebens die scharfe, meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache.
Das Ding ist nur, dass ich die Uhr ständig bearbeite.
Mittlerweile kannst du es halt, ich hab schon fast verlernt, wieder Ruby zu programmieren,
weil man Ruby heutzutage halt nicht mehr braucht.
Und Rails auch auf ein ziemlich...
Ich glaub, man kann doch nicht mal mehr sagen, absteigenden Ast ist.
Rails hat gar kein Ast mehr.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Was?
Hydeify next.
Die Namen von den JavaScript...
top also diese woche hat ja im prinzip was okay ich glaube dass sogar diese woche relativ viel
dort netzzeug trendet weil es gab ja eine neue start net release und es gab jetzt diese diese
microsoft konferenz wo es jede menge talks zu dort nicht gehabt da könnte einiges trenden
wieder okay für alle die sachen heili over engine ihren wollen avalon ja ist wirklich
pock wenn ich wenn ich ja sammeln mögen würde wäre das wahrscheinlich so mein go to cross
platform framework und wenn ich mal cross platform machen muss vielleicht vieler was
ich glücklicherweise eigentlich nie machen muss dann probiere ich vielleicht echt noch
mal mit avalon ja das ist denn den rast placing die fast ansonsten benutze ich nicht nein es ist
es ist es ist written in javascript
das ist das überhaupt innovatives open source visualisierungs tool transformiert jason yamel
xml csv und mehr in interactive crafts okay das könnte man tatsächlich gebrauchen wenn man es
brauche also ich glaube das so typisches tool wenn man es mal brauche es mein froh drüber dass
man es hat das ist glaube ich ganz nice um sich durch ziemlich um sich durch so deep lehnen
nesse jason dinger
durchzuklicken. Ja, ja, ja. Es ist immer eine gute Gelegenheit, in .NET, in C-Sharp einzusteigen.
Wir müssen uns auch noch ein Video angucken, what's new in C-Sharp. Mal gucken, da gibt's
doch bestimmt eins bei, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht jetzt an, aber... Ach, guck mal,
hier ist wieder der Programming-Tierlist, Dude. Den haben wir doch das letzte... Moment,
den haben wir doch das letzte Mal schon. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was da rumkommt. Pass auf,
pass auf, wir, wir, wir chibäden, wir chibäden mal wieder die YouTube-Seite, okay? So, wir gucken
am Ende, was rauskommt. Shorts, Keckel. Das ist ja die weird-champigste Auswahl an
Programmiersprachen, um sie zu ranken überhaupt. Da, da, da fehlt, da fehlt ja gefühlt alles. Aber
Hauptsache, JavaScript ist Goat-S-Tier. Okay, kann man so sehen, aber C++ auf A-Tier setzen.
Guck mal hier, 47 hoch, 40... Ist das Chibate? Ist das ein Chibate-Video, um möglichst viele
Comments zu baiten? Das könnte man machen. Das ist eigentlich absolut Sixthead-Idee. Also,
das hab ich eh, das hab ich auf YouTube auch schon gemerkt. Wenn man viele Kommentare haben will,
muss man absichtlich was Falsches erzählen und möglichst überzeugend sagen, dass sich viele
Leute korrigieren wollen. So, aber Max, bei 2 Minuten 30, das ist nicht korrekt, was du da sagst.
Das ist, das ist eine Verarschung, ne?
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist... Ich glaube, ich glaube, der will uns Chibaten, möglichst viele
Comments baiten. Ähm, ich wollte... What's new in C-Sharp? Da gab's doch letztens erst... Nicht vor
5 Monaten. Auch nicht... Das hier, genau. Also, das gucken wir nicht jetzt, Leute, ja, aber...
Genau. Haben die eigentlich mehr als 720p? Ja, also haben sie es geschafft, 1080p, okay. Ja.
as expected!
Cool!
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab einen sehr guten Meilenann für sie.
Ich für... Ich für, ich für... Ich... Ich bin ja, ich bin ja schon der Meinung, die letzten paar .NET Versionen
sind Open-Source-Unternehmen-Umsetzungen.
Die IT ist es von seiner Firma?
Ja.
Die...
Also, die müssen mich echt überzeugen. Ich fand, die letzten paar C-Sharp-Versionen haben sich – erstens, unfertige Sachen immer mal wieder eingeschlichen
und
Was haut Nintendo raus?
Achso, das Remake.
Und ein paar Sachen
sind auch unnötig
kompliziert mittlerweile.
Das ist doch nichts Neues. Gibt's doch schon ewig.
Automatisches Ausführen.
Aber written in Rust, dann ist es gut.
Blazingly fast.
So.
Was trendet denn in .NET? Lass uns das mal schnell angucken.
Also Avalonia hat's auf jeden Fall verdient.
Für alle,
die es übermäßig kompliziert machen wollen.
Blazer
ist auch so'n Ding.
Also mich würde
nicht wundern, wenn die Maui demnächst
einstellen. Das Microsoft hat ja
einen guten Ruf,
was UI-Frameworks angeht.
Blazer ist ne gute Idee.
Ich muss aber sagen, außer initial, als es rausgekommen ist,
hab ich mich nie groß mehr mit Blazer
beschäftigt, weil ich einfach bis jetzt
nicht so den riesen Anwendungs...
nicht so den riesen Anwendungskram
halt für mich da drin sehe.
Das Coolste, was es
gibt für mich von Blazer ist Blazer Client.
Einseitig, also .NET per Web-Assembly.
Aber das letzte Mal, als ich das geguckt hab,
musstest du da noch ne riesen Runtime
von 8, 9 MB runterladen,
bis es überhaupt losging.
Das kannst du für so interne Business-Anwendungen
sicherlich verwenden, aber für normale Webseiten
eher nicht.
ASP.NET, das hat's
verdient. Meiner Meinung nach das beste
Web-Framework, das es gibt.
Also Backend-Web-Framework,
das es gibt.
WPF-UI.
Irgendjemand, der sich die Mühe gemacht hat,
das WPF, Oldschool-WPF
modern aussehen zu lassen.
Maui.
Ja, dass das überhaupt Sterne bekommt,
verstehe ich nicht.
.NET Runtime, ja, das hat's.
OpenAI, okay, klar, dass das mal...
Ach, das ist
SDK, ja, okay, ergibt Sinn.
Blazer.
AI.
Plotinosi.
Ach, das ist
ein, das ist dieser Windows-11-
Deploter, brauchen wir nicht.
Windows-Proxy. Das ist das, was
früher YARP hieß, oder?
Ist das nicht früher
YARP? Doch.
Das heißt sogar immer noch so.
Aber Hauptsache, Microsoft nennt
das jetzt anders.
Beispielanwendungen.
Irgendein Game? Ohne Screenshots?
Irgendwelche Bindings
für AP-Endpunkte?
Switch-Emulator? Okay, ja.
OSU!
Endlich, Chat. Wo sind...
Wo sind die Weeps?
Also, man kann in OSU
natürlich auch anderes Zeug
machen, aber
ich habe den Eindruck,
dass 99% der OSU-Spieler
irgendwelche Anime-Musik
da drinnen abspielen.
Zack-Hacks-Spoofy?
Massive-Hackerman-Kram?
Hatten wir das nicht grad schon, eShop?
Ach, nee, das ist die Backend-Seite
wahrscheinlich. Azure SDK, okay.
Und Blazer.
Oh.
VRPC.
Counter-Strike-Sharp.
Server-Plugins
in C-Sharp-Verkauf.
Damit, also ich hätte ja mit allem gerechnet,
aber nicht mit sowas hier.
Damit hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet.
Also, du kannst ruhig noch ein paar
posten, wenn es jemand interessiert.
Und, wenn es
jetzt nicht irgendwie 50 Stück sind,
hau rein.
Vielleicht ist auch irgendwas
für mich dabei.
So, dann wissen wir jetzt, was trendet.
Nice, nice.
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Zeig mal, ja.
Mask.
A CLI-Taskrunner, defined by...
Hä? Wozu braucht man sowas?
Written in Rust, was sonst?
Das ist quasi ein Markdown-Make-File,
sozusagen. Sehe ich das richtig?
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Markdown-Make-File, warum nicht?
Gartenkralle.
Danke für den Sub.
Excellent.
Und Matrix HD, auch re-subscribed.
Falls du noch da bist...
Sorry, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Pog-Subscription.
Es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Es braucht man doch bitte.
So, dann machen wir mal Shithub zu.
Yuki Cat, danke für den Sub.
Der Name,
ohne dir zu nah treten zu wollen,
der Name klingt ein bisschen...
Ayaya!
...ein bisschen...
Weeps-In-mäßig.
Alter, wieviel Zeug.
Sag mal, du starst prinzipiell nur Rust-Repos, oder?
Kannst du den Camp-Champ demnächst auch starren?
Also...
Uahhh...
Nope.
Also Chat, was mein'n wir?
Krieg ich's hin bis Ende des Jahres?
Zehn Kilometer unter einer Stunde, oder nicht?
Ich tippe auf, ich krieg's nicht hin.
Easy, na, easy wird...
Es ist nicht easy, Leute.
Man denkt, es ist easy.
Es sind ja nur 4 Minuten 28 weniger.
Aber das bedeutet, ähm...
22 Sekunden pro Kilometer weniger.
Und das ist sehr viel anstrengender.
Also 6 Minuten pro Kilometer ist sehr viel anstrengender als 6 Minuten 22.
Alles Mindset.
Ja, das, das, das Crinder...
Crinder...
Ne, Kreisel-Crind, Crinder-Mindset.
Kreisel-Crind, Crinder-Mindset.
Ich hab' schon mal mit dem Opa an mir vorbei gerannt.
Der war, der war ne ganze Ecke schneller als ich.
Und bestimmt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 70 oder so.
Warum?
Warum ist das grenzwertig?
Es ist halt anstrengend.
Außerdem kommt das immer davon an, was man für maximale Herzfrequenz hat.
Ja, das, das hab' ich jetzt zum ersten Mal...
Das hab' ich zum ersten Mal, seit ich angefangen hab' zu rennen, überhaupt realisiert.
Das die...
Das die doppelt so schnell wie ich rennen und das über 41, 42 Kilometer.
Das ist halt super krass, die Dudes da.
Und...
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, wie krass die Fahrradprofis sind, wenn die da irgendwie mit 6,8 Watt pro Kilogramm den Berg hochflitzen.
Und ich meine Probleme habe, 45 Minuten 2 Watt pro Kilogramm zu drehen.
Ich meine, die sind leichter als ich, aber trotzdem.
Das ist heftig.
Ja, na klar.
Na ja, klar, aber trotzdem.
Das ist echt mega heftig.
Die laufen ungefähr 20...
Ungefähr 20 kmh.
Bisschen, bisschen schneller als 20 kmh laufen die.
Im, im Marathon.
Mal kurz was gucken.
Ja.
Ah ja, guck mal.
Du musst 20 kmh laufen, dass du 40 Kilogramm fährst.
Ja.
Wenn du 40 kmh in 2 Stunden packst, quickmuffs.
Die laufen etwas über 20 kmh.
Das kenne ich, damit haben wir doch sogar schon was gemacht im Stream.
Vor allem, weil das Ding
Kekona heißt.
Beste...
Ich glaube nicht, dass der, dass der in irgendeiner
Art und Weise
an Kekona gedacht hat.
Machst du auch bei so Firmenläufen?
Nö.
Nächstes Jahr laufe ich beim
Frankfurter Challenge Laufen mit, Leute.
Ich glaube ich nur 6 km.
Aber eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock
damit zu laufen.
Weil das so spät ist.
Mit GoPro.
Hänge ich mir eine GoPro um
und flitze los.
Agil, Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, dann gucken wir doch mal, was es jetzt auf YouTube zu gucken
gibt. Hä?
Ja, ja, Moment.
Naja, also 6 kmh ist nicht so
schnell. Okay, na dann.
Ja, ich habe OpenSense
eine Weile bei mir daheim verwendet, aber
jetzt nicht mehr.
Weil ich das alles etwas entzerrt habe
an Geräten. Ich hatte früher viel zu viel auf einer Kiste
laufen. Da kann man sich streiten,
wo die Grenze ist zwischen
quasi Laufen,
also sagen wir mal gehen,
Laufen und Rennen.
So, weil
ich muss sagen, oder sagen wir mal
Joggen, ja? Also Laufen, Joggen,
Rennen. Also ich muss sagen, so
die 6, 6,30 pro Kilometer
oder
6,22, das ist,
das ist auf jeden Fall noch Joggen,
aber es ist so,
es geht auf die Grenze zum Rennen zu.
Also ich würde sagen,
so unter 6, unter 6
oder sagen wir mal, spätestens bei 5,30 ist es
Rennen. Rust, genau.
So, dann
gucken wir mal, was wir uns auf YouTube angucken können.
Was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Copium Time.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist doch, das ist doch
eindeutig Text to Speech, oder?
Claims Apple.
Ja, Apple erzählt viel, wenn er taglang ist.
Apple, oh man, die erzählen auch viel Shit, wenn er
taglang ist.
Linux-Disk richtig verkleinern.
Verkleinern ist in der Tat schwieriger als
erweitern.
So kaputt ist E-Mail und sie wird trotzdem nicht
sterben. Ja, das,
da gehe ich d'accord mit.
Nie mehr arbeiten durch
4%-Regel, alles klar.
Das wird auch immer,
das hat auch immer mehr Community-Gruppe-Vibes.
Coding in C
until I go completely insane.
Okay, im Prinzip,
im Prinzip ist er insane
nach einer Minute.
Let's get started on that homework. Assignment.
Using floating point number...
Oh, ich muss da kurz die Musik ausmachen.
Prove that 0.1 plus 0.2
equals 0.3.
Bonus points, ooh.
If you can use 17 digits of floating point accuracy...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ich weiß,
worauf's rausläuft.
After three failed
attempts, we will power down
your computer. Bro, this one is so easy.
Okay, so include standard.io.h
to get that library in there.
Into main, get your argc
and your argv. Type in real fast
this time. We'll do float a
equals 0.1. Float b
genauigkeit ist so'n Ding, ne?
0.2 and then
we'll do printf with the float type
and print a plus b.
We'll return 0.
Alright, let's get GCC
going. GCC output floats
from homework.c.
Run that, boom, real easy.
Alright, let's get those bonus points.
Add 0.17 here.
GCC again. Pass auf, pass auf.
And easy.
Ja.
What the fuck?
Python, help me out here.
I don't.
I don't understand.
JavaScript, please.
What?
Ja.
Float genauigkeit, das ist
immer so'n Ding.
Angular.
MonkaS, will er sich das wirklich antun?
Hör mal bloß auf.
Was verdient ein Postbot?
Was haben wir denn? Das gucken wir uns
irgendwann mal an.
Postbot ist E-Mail.
Komm, das gucken wir an, die machen doch immer
gute Witz.
Also ich gehe mit dem Überschrift, gehe ich vollkommen
mit, E-Mail ist seit Jahrzehnten
gefühlt kaputt, aber
E-Mail wird
weiterhin eines der wichtigsten
Kommunikationskanäle bleiben.
Ich schreibe eine E-Mail.
Das machen wir.
Ja, fwreforward
re
re re re re
a w f w und dann
ist der
Verteilerkreis bei
alle Antworten auf einmal 60 Leute.
...sogar wöchentlich
als CT3003 Newsletter
und ist aus dem Arbeitsalltag
von fast allen Menschen nicht
wegzudenken. Und bei Betreffzeilen
gilt, je mehr
re doppelpunkt, re doppelpunkt, wgaw
doppelpunkt, desto besser.
Eine E-Mail-Betreffzeile ist erst dann richtig
gut, wenn sie nicht mehr in die Vorschau
auf das Smartphone ist.
Mittlerweile kürzen das ja viele E-Mail-
Clients schon sinnigerweise.
Und natürlich gehören E-Mails auch privat
absolut zum Alltag. Kinokarte
bestellt, klar, kriegst du ne Mail. Spiel auf
der Playsee gekauft, kriegst du ne Mail.
Technik-News-Updates, kriegst du ne Mail.
Und natürlich Spam, kriegst du ganz viele
Mails. Aus technischer Sicht ist die
E-Mail vor allem so erfolgreich, weil
sie dezentral funktioniert. Also
du hast komplett die Wahl, du kannst entweder
deinen eigenen Mail-Server betragen...
Ah, gute alte Sun-Kiste, ja.
Die kenne ich ehrlich gesagt nur
vom Sehen noch.
Und gemacht habe ich damit nie
was. Also während meiner
Ausbildungszeit hatten wir ganz unten
in einem Rack noch
alte, so richtig fette 4HE-Sun-Kisten
stehen. Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht, was die gemacht haben. Bis heute weiß ich nicht,
was die gemacht haben. Die waren einfach nur da.
Und an. Die haben wahrscheinlich
seit 15 Jahren das Gleiche gemacht und die
gingen einfach.
Mainstream bei Google Mail sein oder
og.gmx.de. Gmx.
Ich habe
paar E-Mail-Adressen bei gmx und paar bei
gmail.
Die älteren von mir, die habe ich bei
gmx. Ich habe sogar bei
einer ein gmx-Premium-Abo
für irgendwie 4€ oder so.
Für mehr
IMAP-Speicher. Matthias, danke für den Sub.
Und gmx hatte übrigens
letztens einen größeren Ausfall.
Die waren mal einen halben Tag
nicht erreichbar. Aber es gibt schlimmeres.
Was bei E-Mail?
Bei zentralisierten Diensten wie WhatsApp, Signal
oder Telegram. Da kann man keine eigenen
Server betreiben. Und man hat auch
keine Wahl, wo man den eigenen Account
registriert. Ja, aber leider
hat E-Mail auch ganz viele Nachteile.
Dummerweise auch welche, die sich
prinzipbedingt auch nicht... Zum Beispiel, dass man
schön Absender faken kann.
Ich meine, man kann das.
Mit Signaturen und
Verschlüsselung und so kann man E-Mail ganz
ganz gut
secure machen. Das Ding ist nur, niemand
verwendet es.
Einfach reparieren lassen. Vor allem, was die Sicherheit angeht.
Deshalb wäre es jetzt einfach zu sagen,
die Zeit ist gekommen, E-Mail
stirbt bald. Das haben ja auch schon
viele Leute gesagt. Wir sagen aber,
E-Mail ist nicht tot zu finden.
Warum das so ist, seht ihr in diesem Video.
Und auch, warum E-Mail eigentlich
total kaputt ist. Bleibt dran.
Ja, seh ich auch so.
Hast du schon das
Half-Life Anniversary ab... Was?
Was? Moment!
Was? Was?
Wo? Wo?
Oh, Alter!
Die Seite laggt as fuck!
Ich glaube, wir müssen den Chrome machen für mehr
Grafikbeschleunigung. Ja, läuft gleich viel besser.
Wisst ihr, was mich bei
Half-Life bis heute
verwirrt?
Ich gette, warum es so ist.
Aber Black Mesa hat
überall irgendwie
radioaktives Zeug und giftiges
Zeug rumliegen.
Aber einen Helm
hat dieser Schutzanzug nicht.
Headcrabs
würden überhaupt nicht funktionieren,
wenn es einen Schutzanzug hätte.
Wenn es einen Helm hätte, der Schutzanzug.
Aber die Brille macht das schon.
Und was für
ein Update?
Ja, was gibt es jetzt hier eigentlich
als Update?
Und was sind die...
New Content.
Ja, schön, aber...
Nee, weiter scrollen.
Wir sind doch schon unten.
Ach, Moment!
Ablink!
Ablink war die Demo.
Ablink ist jetzt dabei, okay.
Ablink war die PC-Demo
für Half-Life.
Okay, nice.
Es ist gut, dass es vier neue Multiplayer-Maps gibt.
Kaum einer spielt noch.
Updated Graphics Settings.
Ah, besseres Field of View.
Upscaling.
Restored Content.
Original Main-Menü.
So sah Gordon Freeman in der Alpha aus.
Wobei das noch nicht Gordon Freeman war.
Das war hier Ivan the Space-Biker.
Ja, ja.
Da erkennt man auch noch ein bisschen besser an dieser
Grafik, dass Half-Life ursprünglich
auf der Quake 1-Engine basiert,
finde ich.
Wie Multiplayer-Maps.
Nun ja, es hält sich doch wirklich
sehr in Grenzen.
Original Half-Life Intro-Video.
Improved Physics.
Oh.
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich nichts,
was es mit Mods nicht...
Wir haben es ja letztens wieder durchgespielt
mit M-Mod.
Vor einem halben Jahr oder so.
Es gibt jetzt für mich keinen Grund,
das nochmal durchzuspielen in nächster Zeit.
Okay, gucken wir mal, das wird fertig.
E-Mail, wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internetseller,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Ja, die E-Mail ist tatsächlich älter
als das Internet. Also genau genommen
das Protokoll dahinter.
SMTP, Simple Mail Transfer
Protokoll. Das stammt nämlich aus dem Jahr 1982
und war eigentlich für
ARPANET gedacht. Also dieses
US-Forschungsnetzwerk, aus dem
dann später das Internet hervorgegangen ist.
Warum ist das wichtig? Weil sich da...
Ich erinnere mich noch an in der Berufsschule,
wo sie uns das erklärt haben.
Gab es da nicht noch Aloha oder sowas
als Vorgänger?
Wer hat Internet-History drauf, Leute?
Gab es da nicht noch irgend so ein
Aloha Funk...
oder Alholla oder irgendwie so ähnlich
Aloha Funk-Netzwerk,
wo sie damals auch schon getestet
haben, Netzwerk-Collisions
und sowas.
Das Funk-Netz der Unis auf Hawaii.
Ja, genau.
Irgendwie, ich erinnere
mich noch dunkel dran.
Okay, wir können mal gucken, was die Gamestar dazu sagt.
Dadurch einiges
Erklärenes, womit sich die E-Mail heute noch
herumschlägt. ARPANET war nämlich
ganz anders als das Internet, quasi
so ein Friede-Freude-Eierkuchen-Netzwerk.
Weil es nur von einer kleinen
Forschungs- und Militär-Bubble benutzt
wurde, gab es da keine kriminellen
Angriffe, Spam oder Betrugsmaschen.
Und dieses SMTP-Protokoll
verwenden Mail-Server noch heute...
Gab es am Anfang im Internet auch nicht so viel.
Umso Mainstreamiger das Ganze
geworden ist, umso mehr hat das zugenommen.
Logischerweise. Um miteinander zu kommunizieren.
Wo viele Leute sind, ist viel Geld zu holen,
dann sind die Scammer auch nicht weit.
Wo der Mainstream die Leute sind,
haben die auch weniger Technik-Ahnung
und lassen sich einfacher scammen.
Bei SMTP sind nicht Benutzer oder Organisationen
im Mittelpunkt, sondern Prozesse auf Computern.
Das Ganze ist im Prinzip super simpel,
das erklärt euch jetzt mal Shahin,
der normalerweise hinter der Kamera arbeitet.
Okay, also. Der User ist ein möglicher
Auslöser, der dem sendenden SMTP-Prozess
den Auftrag zum Senden einer
Nachricht gibt. Dieser Prozess baut dann
eine Verbindung zum empfangenden Mail-Server auf
und stellt sich dann mit dem Befehl
Hello, also mit der Abkürzung von Hello...
Aber...
Habt ihr schon mal SMTP per Telnet gemacht?
Das geht im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Sachen
relativ gut.
Da müsst ihr genau sowas eintippen.
Oder einen GET
per Telnet ist auch relativ easy mit
HTTP 1.1.
Zum Beispiel
hellomail.heise.de
und liefert dann, wenn der empfangende Server bereit ist,
eine Nachricht ab. Dafür muss er angeben,
wie der Absender der Nachricht heißt
und er weiß dann, wem sie gehen soll.
Also zum Beispiel mailfrom3003
at ct.de rcpt2
newstips at heise.de
Und ja, das Add-Zeichen gab es auch schon
1982.
Was damals aber noch niemand ahnen konnte,
die Möglichkeit selbst anzugeben,
von wem eine Nachricht kommt, wird später
ausgenutzt für Spam und Spoofing.
Spam zu verwenden ist mit SMTP super einfach.
Man braucht nur ein kleines Programm, das
massenhaft SMTP-Sitzungen eröffnet
und dann Nachrichten bei anderen Servern
verwendet. Das ist auch oft bei Malware so passiert.
Also du kriegst Schadsoftware
und die versendet dann über deinen PC Spam.
Da hatten wir auch schon mal ein Video dazu.
Und auch das sogenannte Spoofing
ist bei SMTP super einfach.
Es kann jeder behaupten, dass die Mail
von irgendeinem Absender kommt.
Also etwa absender at bundeskanzleramt.de
Um dagegen vorzugehen,
wurden dann später Verfahren um
SMTP herumgebaut. Etwa
SPF, DKIM und DMARC.
Wolltest du dich irgendwie selbst
geißeln oder warum machst
du sowas?
Also war das irgendwie Bestrafung für irgendwas?
Oder wolltest
du das machen?
Kann ja sein, manche Leute
peitschen sich aus
und manche Leute programmieren in
C++ und sockets
RAW unter Windows in Mailclient.
Ach für deine
Diplomarbeit, ok ja das ist
ja quasi sowas wie Selbstquälen.
Ein gutes, günstiges
Multimeter. Also
ich kann dir nur sagen was ich für eins
hab, ob das gut ist
weiß ich nicht im Vergleich zu anderen
aber es ist
günstig as fuck und für meine
Zwecke reicht das. Hier
das ist ein
komm her
so ein China-Chinesen Ding ist das
und zwar ein
Track Live
DM
01M
so
ungefähr sieht das aus.
So in der Richtung
sieht das aus, nur das es nicht von
Ai Tam ist.
Also es ist halt ein China-Chinesen Ding.
Ist halt billig
für gute
bezahlst du aber 150 Euro
ähm
das ist halt, naja
es ist
billig. Wenn du was wirklich haben willst
was sehr genau ist
und was irgendwie
noch irgendwie zusätzliche
Features hat, da ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so gut.
Aber was ich auf jeden Fall für
Multimeter empfehlen kann
hat jetzt, ist universal
ja sind
so ein
ein
ein zusätzlicher Pack an Test
Probes und zwar
keine Ahnung kann man sich ja was raussuchen
ja zum Beispiel ein Pack
wo verschiedene Probes
dabei sind. Dass du dann hier die hast
zum Beispiel die du an Drähte dran klemmen kannst
oder dass du so
eine Pinzette hast oder
ähm, was ich auch sehr praktisch finde
ist hier die etwas längeren Kontakte als
die die dabei sind. Also ich benutze mittlerweile
zu 90% nur noch die hier.
Die hier. Die kann man so raus
machen, die kann man so rausfahren
und dann kommt also hier vorne, das ist eigentlich
da ist ein Draht drinne, man drückt hier hinten
drauf, dann kommt hier vorne ein Draht
raus, so mit einem Haken dran
den hakt man ein, dann lässt man los, da hinten
ist eine Feder drin und dann
bleibt der Haken halt quasi am Draht
hängen. Wo man
und das ist halt mega praktisch
weil ich ja meistens das an irgendwelche
Drähte, Kabel, was auch immer
machen will bei irgendwelchen kleinen Schaltungen
und da sind die reinen
Probes wo man einfach nur dagegen halten
muss manchmal
unpraktisch. Ja also so ein zusätzliches
so ein zusätzliches Pack
aus Probes kann ich
jedem empfehlen und am besten ihr kauft euch
die mit den elastischen Kabeln
weil oftmals sind die Kabel die dabei
sind richtig Schrott
am besten, es gibt welche die haben so super elastische Kabel
die sind sehr sehr nice
ja, ansonsten
habe ich keine großartige Empfehlung
NO GOD
PLEASE NO
NO NO
NOOOOOO
Wir fangen jetzt aber nicht davon an
wir gucken jetzt das Video weiter
pass mal auf Modern C... sorry Leute
haha jetzt muss es
wir hatten doch letztens sowas schönes
das ist auch eklig
wir hatten doch ich finde
ich finde es nicht mehr
sorry
also
hier
wo wir gerade dabei sind modernes C++
ist schön
also der Typ der fragt vor 9 Jahren
ok ich gebe zu das ist schon ein bisschen her aber das ist ein gutes Beispiel
so also der fragt
vor 9 Jahren ey wie kann man
in C++ sowas hier machen wie in C Sharp
also Array Filter
nach
nach einem
nach einer Bedingung
also das Array Filter nach einer bestimmten Bedingung
ja zum Beispiel Elemente größer als 2
die akzeptierte Antwort
ist das hier
ich mein seriously
the fuck
standard copyif
foobegin fooend
standard backinserter
was niemand weiß
dass es das gibt überhaupt
es sei denn er weiß es halt
und dann diese tolle Lambda Syntax
das ist normal
wenn man in C++ geht muss das immer sein
also wenn ich das hier sehe
pass mal auf
die Leute wollten sich jetzt noch übertreffen
in diesem
backinserter
die Leute wollten sich jetzt mit den Antworten
hier übertreffen
und Leute es wird immer schlimmer
ich finde das hier schon mega hässlich
übrigens ich verstehe nicht
warum man bei den 5
also hätte erstens
hätte C++ sowas wie Extension Methods
was es schon seit lange als Proposal gibt
wäre super easy sowas zu implementieren
aber
warum man nicht für die 5 meistbenutzten
Standardcontainer
sowas anbietet
weiß ich nicht
das Emote ist mega nice
die Leute haben sich jetzt gedacht
wir müssen das noch übertreffen
also das ist ja schon eklig
ja das ist schon eklig
aber es wird noch besser
in C++ kann man das ganze
nämlich so schreiben
die C++ Leute haben sich nämlich gedacht
weißt du was
anstatt das wir Vector
eine Filtermethode spendieren
sodass man sagen könnte Vector
Filter
gibt es jetzt was neues
Ranges was man aus irgendwelchen
Gründen mit einem overloadeten
Pipe Operator macht
alter
warum also erstens
warum kann man den Pipe Operator überhaupt
overloaden und warum
sich eine komplett neues
Ding ausdenken was es vorher
in der Sprache nicht gegeben hat
um das zu filtern
also das ist schon
ok es mag ein bisschen kürzer
und vielleicht ein bisschen eingängiger sein
aber trotzdem echt weird champ as fuck
und warum
ja gut
Javascript
hat genauso Schwachsinn
mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer noch hier
leeres Array gleich gleich nicht leeres Array
is by the way true
oder was auch nice ist
ähm
new Array join A-M
Batman kommt das hier raus
man versteht Javascript auch nicht
ja
und aber jetzt
die Leute haben sich gedacht ok
die Antworten
die Antworten sind immer noch nicht gut genug
die die hier gegeben haben
und die Antworten sind ja auch halbwegs aktuell
die sind immer noch nicht gut genug
jetzt kommt der nächste
und sagt wie wäre es denn mit Boost
erstmal
in einem Array Boost
inkluden
logisch was sonst
wie könnte man auch davon ausgehen
dass die Standard Library einer Sprache
das Filtern
einer Liste
irgendwie benutzerfreundlich erlaubt
also das ist ja
undenkbar
welche Programmiersprache hat schon
die Möglichkeit Arrays zu filtern
also jetzt kommt Boost rein
daraus wird das hier gemacht
das ist finde ich schon mal
nicht besser als das davor
weil man versteht es wirklich gar nicht mehr
Elements werden gepiped
nach filtert
dann was auch immer
Deckel type Elements
Value type
also
was auch immer hier passiert an der Stelle
und dann wird gefiltert
so und dann haben sie sich gedacht ok
das reicht immer noch nicht
es reicht immer noch nicht
jetzt wird es für Templates erweitert
das reicht immer noch nicht
jetzt machen wir Templates drum herum
oder irgendwas
ne sind das überhaupt schon Templates
ne sind noch keine Templates
jetzt hört es komplett aus
ich habe keine Ahnung mehr
was hier eigentlich passiert
jetzt hört
jetzt ist durch
der nächste hat sich gedacht
das reicht immer noch nicht
lasst uns ein Template draus bauen
wir reden hier
Leute mal ganz ehrlich
wir reden hier davon
eine Liste mit Elementen zu filtern
also quasi eines der absoluten Basics
was du mit einer Liste machen willst
jetzt kommen sie an und bauen hier
irgendwelche komischen Templates drum herum
das ist ihnen immer noch nicht genug
jetzt gibt es hier noch advancedere Templates
Leute es ist so weirdchampig
Alter C++ man
ich komme einfach nicht klar drauf
wisst ihr wisst ihr
es gibt
es gibt ja nicht viele
eine Handvoll
wirklich viel benutzter
Collections
Container in C++
das ist Vector
das ist
vielleicht noch Queue und Stack
und dann noch
1,2 der Dictionary Dinger
ok
und warum
kann man diesen Dingern
einfach ein paar neue Methoden spendieren
zum Beispiel sowas wie Filter
oder Count
oder sowas
so schwer kann es
doch nicht sein
dann hast du 90% der Fälle
abgedeckt
aber ich weiß eh nicht was das C++
Gremium macht
ok wir gucken jetzt weiter
die haben keinen Count
vielleicht habe ich jetzt Mist erzählt aber ich glaube
ich bin hier wohl
hier gelandet
ah
C++ Container
ne hier hatte ich das auf
haben die Count
ok Vector
Begin End
Size
ja Moment
ne die haben keinen Count
die haben Size aber Size ist nicht gleich Count
weil Size
bedeutet
wie groß die Collection gerade
memory technisch
also nicht memory technisch
wie viel Platz die Collection gerade hat
also mal angenommen
du
ich bin mir nicht sicher wie Vector unter der Haube das macht
also normalerweise passiert das ja so
bei
Collections
die nicht
eine fixe Länge haben
wie beispielsweise die Standard C Arrays
da machen die das ja so
damit sie eben
nicht so oft
neues Memory anfordern müssen
und kopieren
das sie immer ums doppelte erweitert wird
also zum Beispiel
man hat ne Liste
man legt nen Vector an
ich vermute einfach mal das es so funktioniert
ich bin mir nicht sicher wie es C++ macht
ob das überhaupt definiert ist
oder ob das pro Implementierung abhängt
zumindest in .NET weiß ich das es so ist
also die machen das so mal angenommen
du legst nen Vector an und schreibst
am Anfang 5 Initial 5 Elemente rein
so
dann fügst du nen 6 Element ein
und der Vector ist nicht groß genug
jetzt könnte der ja Speicher anfordern
für 6 Elemente
alle Elemente rüber kopieren
das ist aber auf Dauer ein bisschen zu lahm
deswegen fordert der Speicher für 10 Elemente an
wenn du das 11 Element einfügst
dann macht er aus 10 Elementen
20 Elementen
wenn du das 21. einfügst
fordert er 40 an
wenn du das 41. einfügst
fordert er 80 an
dann macht er das 40 an
und das ist dann das ganze
das heißt ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob Size wirklich
Count ist
der Element die drin ist
oder
die
theoretisch verfügbare Menge
Return Size
leider ist die Hilfe auch nicht
sonderlich nützlich
also Capacity würde ich sagen
ist auf jeden Fall das
was ich sehe
aber bei C++ weiß man nie so genau
Returns the number of elements in a vector
dann ist Size tatsächlich sowas wie Count
hat denn
hat denn sowas wie Stack
immerhin
also man sieht die Collections in C++
sind äußerst minimalistisch
das ist ja nicht als hätten die viel
und ich finde
also so eine Filter Methode
wäre doch echt durchaus
in Ordnung gewesen
die haben ja nix im Endeffekt
hätte C++ sowas eine Möglichkeit
bestehende Klassen zu erweitern
wäre das mega
weil dann könnte man sich einfach
irgendeine Utility Collections
Library includen
und die Standard Collections hätten auf einmal
Filter Max Min
Durchschnitt und alles mögliche
aber geht ja in C++
nicht richtig
ok weiter im Text
eigentlich wollte ich das E-Mail Video gucken
dafür gibt es Templates
ja aber mit Templates kannst du jetzt nicht
zum Beispiel Vector
ähm
ne Filter Methode verpassen
ich mein ok
ich will nicht ausschließen dass man das mit Vectors nicht doch machen kann
mit Vectors kann man
mit Templates nicht doch machen kann
mit Templates kann man irgendwie alles machen
irgendwie wenn man weiß wie
aber ich glaube das geht nicht
ja aber ich finde das blöd
dann läuft das auf sowas raus
Back Inserter Standard
Copy If
warum nicht
warum nicht einfach in die 5 meist benutzten
Collections ne Filter Methode einbauen
das ist doch 90% das
sag mal guck mal
es werden zu 90% so 5 Standard Collections verwendet
und zum Filtern
wird zu 90% von diesen 90%
verwendeten Collections
möchte man eben den Inhalt filtern
mit irgendeinem Callback
so warum kann man
ich mein warum kann man das nicht einfach
einbauen so so wird
es macht doch
man könnte es ja durchaus auch anbieten
als hier
Standard Filter sonst was
aber eben
bei den Collections halt ne
Methode einfügen
die Filter heißt
die im Zweifelsfall
die im Zweifelsfall einfach
das eben für die Standard
für die 5 meist benutzten Standard Collections
mit irgendwas was schon
vorhanden ist im Framework halt wrapped nochmal
übrigens die
C++ Standard Library hat
bis heute kein http Client
jetzt kommen die Leute sagen Rust
auch nicht ok ja
ich finde ne moderne Sprache sollte das haben
und selbst wenn man sagt es ist irgendwie
optional meinetwegen
das Problem ist halt auch das es keine Standard
Implementierung der C++ Standard Library
gibt wofür das C++
Gremium irgendwie zuständig wäre
ich mein es gibt so
sag mal de facto Standards
ja du hast die
GCC Sache und du hast die
LLVM
Geschichte
aber
wenn die ich bin mir sicher
wenn das C++ Gremium
den Shit den die sich
ausdenken selbst auch implementieren
müssten wäre vieles besser
gelöst ja es ist auch noch
so ein Ding ja so ist es
echt ja es ist echt so
es ist auch so ein Ding
du kannst in jeder Programmiersprache die mir
so einfällt also mal COBOL und so
aus den vor jeder halbwegs modernen
Programmiersprache kannst du
weil das ist ja auch ein schönes Beispiel
kannst du einfach da hast du
einfach irgendeine Date Duration
was auch immer klasse dann sagst
du Date Time Now
und das ganze bitte
den Sekundenanteil und den
Sekundenanteil bitte in Millisekunden
ist eigentlich super
easy so und jetzt
kommt die C++ Variante
und das geht noch das geht
noch es gibt es gibt es gibt durchaus es
gibt also es gibt schlimmeres aber
ich mein seriously
ok also erstmal das ganze
hier um Time Now das ist ok
das lass ich mir gefallen so
dass man Zeiten
voneinander abziehen kann und am Ende
kommen Sekunden raus auch ok
so aber
was ist das hier denn schon bitteschön wieder
Standard Chrono
Duration Casts
Microseconds
was ein Alias ist für
Standard Chrono Millisecond
sorry Milliseconds nicht Microseconds
also eigentlich korrekt
geschrieben wäre das Standard Chrono
Duration Casts
Standard Chrono Milliseconds
ähm hier
musst du dann halt Seconds reinstecken weil
weil du es wissen musst
und das artet komplett aus
Mann guckt euch
das an Mann und das ist noch
eines der einfacheren Sachen in der Standard
Library MonkaS
alter wir brauchen das hier
echt brauchen wir das
ja für C++ passt das
12 Different Ways to Filter
Containers in Modern C++
ok Leute sorry für
Side getrackt werden aber ich muss
ein bisschen ranten über C++ jetzt
wir brauchen
Cakebeer ja
hat noch keiner ein sinnvolles Emote
gebastelt
ich bin selbst zu faul
also ich muss sagen es macht durchaus Sinn
in manchen Bereichen C++ zu verwenden
so ist es nicht ich mag die Sprache Plus nicht
zum Beispiel ESP32
ja das war ein riesen
das war ein 1024x1024
Bild da kann ich nichts mehr anfangen
also ESP32
macht Bock zu programmieren auch in C++
wenn da halt nicht die
C++ aber viele Sachen die
sich ausgedacht haben sind halt PP
ans Trinken erinnert nice habe ich gerade
ok also
12 Different Ways to Filter
Containers in Modern also
das Ding ist halt schon mal warum
gibt es überhaupt 12 Different Ways
zu Container zu filtern
was ich brauche Twitch
Emotes sind
32x23 ich weiß es gar nicht
128x128
aber dein Emote war auch nicht
war auch nicht
keck genug oder
ok was haben wir
Filter Raw
weg ok das geht
ok
also das ist ja noch irgendwie
also ich finde das
hier schon nicht gut
we can use it like the
also ich finde ja das hier schon nicht gut
ich persönlich fände es besser man könnte schreiben
weg.filter ok
aber nein das geht ja nicht
ok 12x
good old raw loops das ist der go way
das
warum um alles in der Welt muss das in einem Template sein
ach so ja weil
ja weil die Elemente ja unterschiedlich sein können
ok verstehe verstehe macht Sinn
also das ist der go way
das ist auch so ein Ding wo ich immer kecken muss
bei den go Leuten
so nach dem Motto ey ich habe eine Liste und würde die gerne filtern
die Antwort der go Leute ist immer
ja loop just loop
loop and if ist die Standard
Antwort von den go Leuten
wobei ich glaube mittlerweile
dadurch das go
wenn auch etwas painst champige
generics mittlerweile generics hat
glaube ich das ist mittlerweile
halbwegs brauchbar ich glaube ich weiß es
nicht ja vielleicht kennt ihr eine
ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile auch halbwegs
sinnige
generic go libraries zum filtern
von Listen
die gibt es schon länger die waren halt aktuell in go
also die waren eine ganze Zeit lang in go richtig schlecht
weil die alle quasi
ja nur object verwendet haben
also wie heißt das in go
interface auf
also ganz ehrlich ich wüsste nicht
wie ich den Array anders filtern soll für
Spieleprogrammierung als für Microcontroller
Programmierung letztendlich ist es
eine Schleife mit einem if drin
man kann doch eine sagen wir mal
sinnvolle
Altimplementierung wählen und jeder
der das Array anders
Filtern möchte
kann das ja selbst machen wenn er da Bock drauf hat
und das für ihn nicht passt
so macht das jede x beliebige andere Sprache auch
es gibt guck mal
zum Beispiel Suchalgorithmen
die meisten Programmiersprachen bieten mittlerweile
eine Sortmethode
was übrigens glaube ich C++
für Vector auch nicht hat
C++ Vector Sort
ich glaube gibt es auch nicht oder
dafür gibt es Standard Sort also
so gut wie jede Programmiersprache bietet an
dass man beispielsweise Listen
sortieren kann die haben
eine halbwegs sinnvolle
Default Sortieralgorithmus
die meisten haben so eine Mischung aus
Quicksort für längere Sachen und
irgendwie fragt mich nicht irgendwas
was schnell ist für kleinere Sachen ok
und das switchen die
anhand der Länge die haben eine sinnvolle Default
Implementierung wenn jetzt einer sagt ey
für meinen Anwendungsfall ist die Default
Quicksort Implementierung kacke
da kann er das ja kann er ja was eigenes
verwenden und das könnten die bei
C++ genauso machen eine sinnvolle
Default Implementierung die für
sagen wir mal 90% der Fälle gut ist
und ich meine ein Array zu filtern ja
eine Schleife drüber zu machen mit einem
if drinne ist glaube ich erstmal eine
ganz sinnvolle Default Implementierung
und ja C Sharp
macht das auch C Sharp verwendet auch
eine Mischung aus Heapsort
Quicksort und noch was
fürs Sortieren
ok
Raw Loops damit gehe ich
das passt was richtig
advanced wäre Chatge
was richtig cool wäre
wenn man keinen neuen Vektor Allocaten
müsste sondern
einfach nur einen View in den alten
Vektor liefern könnte mit den
gefundenen Elementen falls das
falls das
irgendwie geht ja also
das finde ich durchaus sinnvoll eine Schleife
und drüber ok weiter gehts Filter by
standard copy if ok
seriously das hatten wir gerade schon
keiner checkt was ist ja doch man checkt
schon aber umständlich
remove copy if ok
im Prinzip
im Prinzip das umgedrehte
es wird nicht kopiert in was neues
sondern es wird
removed das nur noch das übrig bleibt
was man haben will
the famous remove
the famous remove erase was
ok was
Auto Vector
Chat warum
übergeben die hier einen Vektor und weisen den
zu aber ich versteh nicht
out erase
standard remove if
begin end standard
not fnp end
was zum
was
creates a forwarding call
wrapper that returns
the negation of the
callable object
hä
ich hab das jetzt gelesen
ich weiß nicht was die mir sagen wollen
what
was anderes fällt mir
dazu echt nicht mehr ein wenn ich das sehe
alter
ok das ist nichts was man
selbst schreiben muss das ist ja quasi nur die
Definition was du da reinschieben kannst
einmal gibt es irgendjemand der das hier lesen
kann
exzellentes Beispiel
irgendjemand der
die Docs gelesen hat
dieses Beispiel ist die
perfekte Demonstration für dieses Feature
niemand kann es lesen
niemand versteht's
what the fuck man
template class Punkt Punkt Punkt
standard enable if t
negate invokable
constexpr
deckel type auto operator
args und und
args und und Punkt Punkt Punkt
args
const und und
noexpt
standard
move forward
args
ey die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht
die sind
die sind einfach echt komplett wir
ok ok
es wird immer moderner Leute
es wird immer moderner
adding some c++
standard erase if
out not fn
at
hat
verbreitet
man könnte fast sagen es ist lesbar
man könnte fast sagen eins ist lesbar nur mit dem
Unterschied dass keiner checkt was es
eigentlich macht
und warum eine Function Not a Function
ist verstehe ich nicht
Das führt das aus, der Return-Wert ist ein Buhl.
Der macht im Prinzip einfach, der macht ein Ausrufezeichen davor.
Das ist quasi, er führt das aus und das Ergebnis Not.
Aber warum, aber warum braucht man dafür Standard Not FN?
Warum kann ich nicht, ich meine seriously, warum kann ich nicht einfach schreiben?
Ups.
Jetzt mal, äh, Code, what?
Code, Code.
Warum kann ich nicht einfach schreiben, Zack, mach mal hier, so, einfügen.
Boah, Boah, Visual Studio Code, man fackt mich denn ab.
Warum kann ich nicht einfach schreiben, ähm, P, entweder so oder, oder, ähm, warum kann ich nicht einfach, im Zweifelsfall mach ich halt, mach ich halt so.
Ich meine, es ist, dank der ekligen C++ Lambda Syntax ist es auch nicht viel schöner.
Aber ich finde das immer noch besser als Standard Not FN.
Ja, dass ich es nicht direkt callen kann, verstehe ich.
Aber, ich meine, das müsste doch mehr oder weniger äquivalent dazu sein, oder?
Ach, Moment, Moment, hier kommt ja noch, Moment, hier kommt noch X rein.
So, so müsste das sein, so, so, sorry, sorry.
Weil, weil wir bekommen ja quasi ein Element pro, pro, das hier wäre doch vollkommen okay, oder?
Not FN ist ein richtiger Kackname, du denkst, es ist Not a Function.
Dabei ist es einfach, das müsste Negate FN oder sowas heißen, irgendwie, dann würdest du es verstehen.
Aber, ich meine, ganz ehrlich, das hier würde, also ich würde es eh anders nennen.
Bei mir würde das Ding beispielsweise, ähm, nicht P heißen, sondern, sondern sagen wir mal irgendwie Filter oder sowas.
Oder, oder einfach nur Callback, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Oder Filter Callback, irgendwie sowas würde ich das nennen.
So, also, ich finde das hier wäre jetzt halbwegs lesbar, oder?
Dann würde man verstehen, was es macht.
Es bekommt ein Element, ich bin mir übrigens nicht sicher, ob das Welle C++ ist, aber ich finde es lesbar.
Du bekommst ein Element pro Durchlauf, äh, schiebst das in die Filterfunktion und am Ende, das Returned Bool, und am Ende negatest du das.
Und am besten wäre es, wenn du nicht mal die Klammern brauchst, weil es einfach nur ein Ausdruck ist und man könnte im Endeffekt sowas machen.
Aber, ey, ey, das ist glaube ich, das war nicht im Scope für das C++.
C++ Creme, um das irgendwie lesbar zu machen.
Muss X nicht eine Referenz sein?
Doch, kann sein.
Ja, also, naja gut.
Das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen lesbarer.
Egal, weiter, was kann man sonst noch machen?
Ich weiß, ich bin hyper sidetracked, aber ein bisschen C++ Flame muss sein.
Ich finde das hier nicht lesbarer als eine Schleife, ehrlich gesagt.
The Famous Remove, das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Moment, das ist wieder was anderes.
Hä?
C++?
Adding some C++ 20 ranges.
Standard ranges copy if.
Back-Inserter.
Macht's auch nicht schöner.
Making it more generic.
Okay, jetzt kommt der Abfuck mit irgendwelchen Templates drumherum.
Alter!
Ja, ist klar.
Also, ich habe ja gestern schon darüber geflamed, dass Rust teilweise schwer lesbar ist.
Okay.
Es ist eine generic Function mit
einem Parameter T-Con, also Typ T-Con, Typ...
Okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Das ist quasi das gleiche, wie wenn ich in C-Sharp schreiben würde, ja, T und P oder so, ja.
Bloß, dass es komplizierter ist.
Return-Typ Auto.
Okay, Filter-Parameter.
Done.
Ercheckt zur Compile-Zeit.
Jetzt hört es schon wieder auf.
Const-Expr.
Also, das ist Compile-Time-Magic.
Has Pushback.
Ah, ah ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Die checken, ob die Collection, auf die man das anwendet, eine Methode Has Pushback hat.
Es ist mega cool, dass C++ sowas erlaubt, so Compile-Time-Checks.
Das ist richtig pock, macht es aber artet aus und macht es teilweise unnötig kompliziert.
Ich finde, diese Compile-Time-Auswertung in Templates ist eines der geilsten Features von C++,
aber auch gleichzeitig eines dessen, was es zu dieser Ausgeburt der Hölle an Programmiersprache,
macht, die es ist, mitmacht dazu, was es ist.
Also, sie checken hier quasi zur Compile-Time, ob der Vector-Typ, den man hier eben als,
also der Collection-Typ, den man hier reingeschoben hat, ob der eine Methode Has Pushback hat.
So, wenn er das hat, dann verwendet er Standard-Copy-If Back-Inserter.
Wenn er das nicht hat, dann verwendet er Standard-Copy-If Inserter.
Macht Sinn, macht Sinn.
Wenn ich mal sowas wie Extension-Methods hätten,
dann würde ich das auch mal machen.
Dann könnte man eine richtig schöne Sprache draus machen.
Okay, so, wir waren eigentlich...
SICK hat aber auch eklige Syntax.
SICK hat irgendwie Punkt-Stern, Punkt-Stern und so komische Dinger.
So, wir waren eigentlich, wie wir jetzt super krass side-getrackt sind soweit, weiß ich auch nicht.
Eigentlich waren wir gerne dabei, uns ein Video darüber anzugucken,
das E-Mail am Arsch ist und aber trotzdem da bleiben wird.
Was ich übrigens ganz genau...
Ich spule mal kurz zurück.
Hast du mal C++ länger programmiert?
Naja, länger ist Definitionsfrage.
Ich bastel öfters mal eigene ESP32-Firmware.
Und das ist halt C++.
Also, eigentlich ist ESP32 reines C, die Standard-Library vom Hersteller.
Aber ich verwende ganz gern die Standard-Library vom Hersteller
mit ein bisschen Arduino-Library-Stelz obendrauf.
Und das ist C++.
Das heißt, ich programmiere die ESP32 immer in C++.
Wir haben ja auch...
Und das...
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das Advancedeste, was ich bisher je in C++ programmiert habe,
ist das hier gewesen.
Das muss ich, ähm...
Wobblors...
Im Archiv...
Hier, FFM...
Oh, ist das Archiv-Proken, Leute?
Max, Archiv ist...
Nee, ist es nicht.
Okay, war einfach.
Oh, oh, hier!
Massive!
Massive neue Suche vom Archiv, Alter!
Ja!
Max, guck mal, Bug entdeckt.
Hier müsste eigentlich ein Cursor kommen, wenn man da drüber geht, oder?
Wäre viel nicer.
Aber die Seite hast du richtig poggers gemacht.
Richtig poggers.
Ich finde die mega gut.
Die Archiv-Seite.
So, Stream, aber hier müsste trotzdem ein Balken kommen.
FFM-Pack, C++, Stream-Titel.
Hier, WebAssembly, FFM-Pack, C++.
Das war eines der advancesten High-IQ-Sachen, die ich bisher gebaut habe.
Und zwar, man sieht es hier.
Wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut.
Man sieht hier nebenan auch Video-Abspielen.
Und jetzt, passt mal auf, haltet euch fest.
Was war...
Hier, guckt mal.
Das im Archiv...
Also, ich habe erstens das Archiv gelobt, dass es eine mega-Poggers-Seite ist,
dass du das richtig gut hingekriegt hast.
Und das Zweite ist, ich glaube, hier müsste man anstatt der Hand einen Cursor anzeigen.
Äh, keinen Cursor.
So einen...
So einen, ja, Cursor-Balken für Text.
Also, einfach CSS ändern, Cursor-Modus auf Balken, ja.
Aber letztendlich sind ja nur Kleinigkeiten.
So.
Und zwar, was wir in dem Stream gebaut haben, ist Folgendes.
Wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut für den Browser.
Jetzt denkt ihr euch, Videoplayer im Browser gibt es doch jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ihr seht hier vielleicht meine Test-Videodateien.
Ich hatte eine Fernsehaufnahme in...
äh, PAL, 30 FPS in MPEG-2.
Und Frage an den Chat.
Kann ein Browser normalerweise Fernsehaufnahmen in MPEG-2-TS abspielen?
Rein rhetorische Frage.
Nein, kann er nicht.
Das heißt, wir hatten eine Videodatei in einem Format, das der Browser nicht kann.
So, und was wir jetzt gebaut haben, ist, wir haben in C++ mit FFmpeg zusammen
einen Transcoder gebaut.
Der liest die Datei ein, weil FFmpeg kann...
Wir haben das Ganze und...
Transcoder ist falsches Wort. Bestimmt nicht.
Wir lesen die Datei ein in FFmpeg, weil FFmpeg versteht ganz normales MPEG-2-TS.
Dann haben wir die einzelnen Frames extrahiert, umgewandelt in ein Farbformat,
was ein Canvas-Element im Browser darstellen kann.
Und dann haben wir das Ganze per WebAssembly kompiliert und im Browser laufen lassen.
Und im Hintergrund wurden die Videodateien dynamisch gestreamt vom Server.
Das war richtig High-IQ-Stream.
Dynamisch Video gestreamt vom Server, per WebAssembly kompiliertes C++ im Browser laufen lassen,
mit FFmpeg, das die Videodateien rein streamt, einzelne Frames extrahiert,
umwandelt in ein Farbformat, was der Browser versteht und dann auf dem Canvas rendert.
Und man muss dazu sagen, das lief ziemlich gut, Leute.
Das lief hier, ich habe hier kaum CPU-Last und das lief in Echtzeit.
Ich meine, gut, das war Paarlauflösung, 30 FPS, ja.
Aber guck hier, Kodak MPEG-2 Video, das kann der Browser, also ich muss mal sagen,
der Browser spielt damit ein Video ab, was der Browser normalerweise nicht abspielen könnte,
weil er keinen Kodak dafür hat.
Das ist mega nice gewesen.
Ich meine, wie praktikabel es ist, wie praktikabel es ist,
sei mal dahingestellt, weil die meisten Leute wollen ja vielleicht 1080p-Plus-Videos gucken,
sag mal, 1080p, 60 FPS und höher Videos, die nicht in Formaten sind heutzutage,
die der Browser kann.
Das ist ein bisschen, ja, also ich glaube, das Maximale, was wir hingekriegt haben,
im Browser zu rendern, waren tatsächlich 1080p, 60 FPS, nach einigem Optimieren.
Und danach war Schluss.
Aber es ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
So ein bisschen wie ein Browser-Plugin früher, komplett mit WebAssembly.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wo ich das Projekt noch rumliegen habe.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Habe ich das alte Projekt hier eigentlich noch irgendwo?
Wie hieß das denn?
Monka CPP.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz gucken, ob ich das noch irgendwo habe.
Das ist hier.
Monka C... Ah, da ist es noch! Monka CPP.
Ich habe den Source-Code sogar noch.
Ja, Repos, Monka CPP, da ist alles noch.
Man könnte fast mal überlegen, das irgendwann noch mal schön zu machen und auf GitHub zu pushen.
Weil ich glaube, da für ein Exempel wäre für viele Leute hilfreich.
Das war nämlich wirklich nicht straight-forward.
Es gibt ein paar Beispiele für C++ WebAssembly mit FFmpeg,
aber die benutzen immer nur statische Video-Files.
Wir haben ja wirklich das Video gestreamt vom Server in den Browser.
Also man musste nicht vorher sich 500 MB Video runterladen.
Nein, nein, man hat sich immer nur häppchenweise Video runtergeladen.
Ich mache das mal kurz hier in Visual Studio Code auf.
Gucke mir mal meinen eigenen Kram an.
Sorry, heute nicht super.
Sidetrack stellt es am Start.
Aber die...
Hier, HTML-Index.
Genau, hier in das Canvas wird es am Ende gerendert.
mp4-info.js
Da ist irgendwas übrig geblieben.
Das ist nichts von mir.
So.
Dann haben wir sogar noch irgendwelche...
Genau, wir rendern ja sogar...
Moment, das ist ja noch advanceder als ich gedacht habe.
Wir rendern sogar ja per WebGL rein.
Wir rendern ja sogar noch Grafikkarten accelerated in das Canvas rein.
So.
Und am Ende streamt er irgendwie vom Server runter das Ganze.
Hier mp4-info.
What the fuck, das ist generated auf jeden Fall.
Server.js
Worker.js
Render.js
Was zum Geier.
Das haben wir doch im Leben nicht selbst geschrieben hier, oder?
What the fuck.
Ah, ne.
Das habe ich copy-pasted von GitHub.
Das ist Colorspace Conversion.
Also von RGB zu JuV als WebGL Shader.
Alter, das Projekt ist ja advanceder gewesen, als ich das in Erinnerung habe.
Colorspace Conversion als GPU Shader.
Meine Güte, das ist ja super advanceder Shit, was wir hier gebaut haben, ey.
Kann ich mich überhaupt noch mal richtig dran erinnern.
MonkaS, man.
Das habe ich gemacht, weil das normale Canvas gelaggt hat.
Ja, okay.
Und wo ist hier das Streamen gewesen?
Vom...
Vom Server.
Ah, hier.
Fetch.
Genau.
Hier.
Fetch.
Reader.
Richtig.
So.
Was passiert mit dem Reader?
Ah, das habe ich irgendwie auskommentiert, weil es irgendwie kaputt war.
Kann das sein?
Fetch.
Video.
Was auch immer.
Es hat funktioniert.
Man sieht es ja im Stream.
Okay.
Jetzt genug Sidetracked.
Weiter geht's.
Das war wirklich ganz abgedrehter Kram, den wir mal gemacht haben.
Okay.
Eigentlich waren wir dabei, ein Video zu gucken, das E-Mail kaputt ist und trotzdem weiter
existieren wird.
Gut.
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken jetzt echt das Video.
Sonst wird das heute gar nichts mehr.
Matthias, Dev, danke für den Sub.
Wobei, habe ich, glaube ich, vorhin schon gesehen, oder?
Egal.
Trotzdem.
Nice.
Wir sind etwas abgedriftet.
Etwas abgedriftet ist gut.
Ich glaube, wir sind eine Stunde lang abgedriftet oder so jetzt.
Ich bin zwei Stunden on und wir haben nicht mal ein Video geguckt.
Zu drei Minuten von einem Video in zwei Stunden.
Null.
Okay.
Ja, at bundeskanzleramt.de.
Um dagegen vorzugehen, wurden dann später Verfahren, um es im Thema E-Mail kaputt zu
machen.
Also, ich glaube, das ist ein guter Satz.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt merkt man schon mal, dass weißt du, wir haben alle recht sekarang auf
wir finden auch noch mal eine söyleyebene Perle in dem Thema e-Mail.
Wenn wir überhaupt da sagen, na ja, ja, ja das ist so.
Aber irgendwie wissen wir das.
Ja, genau.
Der wird natürlich dann vor einen Moment, LC, zu mir kommen und sagen, Denvinas.
Der zeigt, wie eure Strahlung aussieht, ist eine der Grund useful.
Aber von der Seite her, wir finden es ganzicana sch reignig.
AlsOP.
kenne ich gar nicht sollten auf grundlage von kryptografie und dns für mehr sicherheit sorgen
aber weil die e mail ja möglichst einfach zugänglich sein sollte und es keine zentrale
steuerungsinstanz gibt wurden diese sicherheitsmechanismen nie irgendwie verpflichtend
eingeführt also so als update von smtp 10 auf 20 selbst dinge die heute eigentlich selbstverständlich
sind wie die transportverschlüsselung tls sind nicht verpflichtend es weigern sich halt nur
immer mehr mail server e mail zu empfangen bei denen die sogenannte obligatorische transport
verschlüsselung nicht aktiviert ist auch eine andere entscheidung von damals hat heute noch
konsequenzen der inhalt einer mail nach dem damaligen standard darf nur aus asky zeichen
stehen alle buchstaben zeilen und zeichen die man in den usa braucht aber eben keine umlaute wie er
oder chinesische schriftzeichen ich dachte das war mir gar nicht klar dass das so ist ich dachte das
ist letztendlich von der meisten kinesischen kinesischen kinesischen kinesischen kinesischen
system mancheck dann kann man es auch alsikitiert natürlich vorausgesetzt man Loop shouldn't be
greens mit iCity oder also issues unter einem meiden her gut nee wobei macht schon Remembering
ist kann väldigt wichtig denn das ganze interoperabel sein muss mit anderen anderen
mitsaubert ob es er glaube ich kein Mattloc-Nachhalt Stonewalls undteen in welchem
entwicklungsgesicht unterому ebenen die e mailxx ist ob wobei ich elle trinkез den
der eine dass ich letztens eine e maillaughter zu älterem curb matrimonial angeematicming
ist und irgendwie glaube ich auch texting cash nel슨 manche kelp
Ja gut, dass es im Domain-Part funktioniert, verstehe ich, aber funktioniert es auch im User-Part?
Das war damals auch okay und schon zeitgemäß.
Es ging ja primär darum, kurze Nachrichten zu übermitteln auf textbasierten Terminals oder Nadeldruckern.
Und das Ganze in den USA.
Aber gut, das hat sich dann offensichtlich später etwas geändert und mit MIME, Multipurpose Internet Mail Extension,
gab es dann neue Spezifikationen, die quasi alles können.
Unicode-Zeichen, Anhänger...
Ja, in MIME gibt es auch unterschiedliche Typen für das Gleiche, wie viele Plaintext-Typen und sowas da alles gibt.
Und Verschachtelung von Inhalten.
Ich habe ja Anfang schon gesagt, der große Vorteil an der E-Mail ist die dezentrale Struktur.
Das ist aber halt auch das größte Problem.
Das hat nämlich ab den 2000ern zu einer regelrechten Welle an Spam-Mails geführt,
eben weil es alle benutzen und man mit Spam super viele Leute erreicht.
Und auch wenn Spam etwas zurückgegangen ist,
laut einer Aussage...
Bei der Auswertung von Kaspersky Labs aus dem Jahr 2022 lag der Anteil an Spam-Mails da immer noch bei 45%.
Und alle, die schon mal einen Mail-Server selbst betrieben haben, wissen,
da den ganzen Spam zu filtern, ist ganz schön nervenaufreibend.
Und wird jetzt mit KI-Textgeneratoren auch nicht einfacher.
Was aber noch schwieriger ist, ist das Sicherstellen, dass andere Mail-Server meine Mails auch empfangen.
Da hatten wir bei der CT vor kurzem echte Probleme, weil Google-Mails die KGE als Spam schleudern.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, ja, ist schon blöd, weil dann konnte ja niemand mehr bei CT an Gmail-Adressen Mails versenden.
Ja, aber es ist tatsächlich noch viel schlimmer gewesen.
Denn die Google-Server hosten nicht nur Google-Mail-Adressen, sondern auch die Mails von vielen Unternehmen,
die ihre Mails samt Domain einfach von Google verwalten lassen, statt einen eigenen Mail-Server zu verwenden.
Das war ziemlich doof für uns und das passiert auch regelmäßig anderen Firmen.
Also, dass die Reputation ihrer Mail-Domain von Google abrupt runtergestuft wird und keine Mails mehr...
Du bist da halt...
Der Trend geht auch deshalb zu zentralen Mail-Adressen...
Bei den Google-Services bist du halt immer Google so auf Gedeih und Verderben ausgeliefert.
Du kannst dann da zwar hinschreiben und wenn du Glück hast, vielleicht in einem Monat oder so,
haben sie es mal dann verifiziert und dich wieder rausgenommen oder irgendjemand, der keinen Bock hat,
hat drauf geguckt und dich drin gelassen.
Hast halt gelitten, ne?
In Google.
Denn wenn ich jetzt für mein Unternehmen einen eigenen Mail-Server betreibe und dann aber immer Angst haben muss,
dass andere größere Mail-Server meine Mails nicht empfangen, das ist nicht so gut.
Dann beiß ich...
Dann beiß ich halt in den sauren Apfel und gebe zum Beispiel Google Geld...
Ja, gebe ich dir recht.
Vor allem Outlook ist wirklich fragwürdig mittlerweile.
Also Outlook gab es ja jetzt vermehrt Nachrichten darüber...
Moment.
Bei Outlook gab es jetzt ja vermehrt Nachrichten darüber, dass sie den E-Mail-Inhalt scannen
und, jetzt kommt's, sogar verschlüsselte Anhänge versuchen zu entpacken mit einer Standard-Passwort-Liste.
Also ihr stellt euch mal vor, ihr verschickt einen Zip,
ihr habt als E-Mail-Anhang,
warum auch immer ihr das macht,
und ihr habt als Passwort
kekw123
und dieses Passwort ist auf einer Passwort-Liste,
dann verschlüsselt Microsoft euren Anhang und scannt den auch.
Ja.
Dazu kommt, dass es jetzt immer weitere, immer weitere Probleme gibt.
Leute, die beispielsweise ihre E-Mail-Sachen mit Outlook synchen lassen,
mit dem Cloud-Outlook,
dann kopiert er quasi den kompletten E-Mail-Folder,
in die Cloud bei Microsoft, was viele Leute gar nicht haben wollen.
Da gab's doch letztens Outlook-Copy-Mails.
Da gab's doch letztens den ersten News-News-Post dazu.
Ja.
Hier, das da, zum Beispiel.
Weiß nicht, von welcher Seite.
New Outlook Copies, also es geht jetzt nicht um ein Outlook.com E-Mail-Postfach,
sondern Outlook als E-Mail-Client, ja.
Und wenn ihr Outlook als E-Mail-Client verwendet,
kopiert, ich glaube sogar mit den Standard-Settings,
und ihr beispielsweise euren Gmx oder Google-Mail-Account in der Outlook-App hinzufügt,
dann werden die Mails jetzt quasi kopiert zu Microsoft.
Ob man das will oder nicht.
Ist halt schon ziemlich für'n Arsch, ne?
Also ich, da mach ich echt einen großen Bogen drum.
Ich verwende nach wie vor Thunderbird.
Das wurde letztens geupdatet, sieht jetzt ein bisschen moderner aus,
aber irgendwie auch viel langsamer geworden.
Ja, äh, Thunderbird.
Ich hab jegliche aktiven Inhalte für E-Mails aus.
Alles Plaintext angezeigt.
Meinung zum OpenAI-Drama.
Ich habe, was, was für ein Drama.
Ich habe das OpenAI-Drama nicht mitbekommen.
Was ist da, was ist da los?
Na, wir gucken jetzt erst mal das Video fertig.
... dass die das Mail-Hosting für mich übernehmen
und die Mails dann auch sicher bei Google und den anderen großen Anbietern.
ankommen.
Fällt im ersten Moment auch gar nicht auf,
weil ich ja meine eigene Domain verwenden kann.
Aber das zerstört natürlich auch die Grundidee vom dezentralen System E-Mail.
So, man kann ja nicht über die E-Mails...
Sie haben den Chef rausgeschmissen bei OpenAI.
Wahrscheinlich hat er Scheiße gebaut, oder?
Oh, was war das Problem?
... ohne E-Mail-Client zu erwähnen.
Klar, viele Mail-Anbieter wie Google, Microsoft oder Apple
bieten einen Browser-Zugang auf die eigenen Mails an
und am Desktop ist das inzwischen für viele Leute der gängigste Weg.
Für einige geht es aber noch über die klassischen Mail-Programme am Rechner oder Smartphone.
Für mich zum Beispiel.
Ich benutze auf allen Betriebssystemen am liebsten Thunderbird.
Ich auch.
Das ist Open Source, was ich grundsätzlich bevorzuge.
Und seit dem Supernova-Update sieht es auch wirklich ziemlich gut aus.
Das Problem allerdings...
... ist langsam S-Fuck geworden seit dem Update.
... mit den ganzen unterschiedlichen Clients.
Alle machen irgendwas anders und man kann sich nie so genau darauf verlassen,
dass die E-Mail beim Empfänger auch wirklich so aussieht, wie man sich das wünscht.
Was da helfen kann...
Das stimmt.
HTML-E-Mails ist eh eines der dümmsten Erfindungen ever.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich hab's schon erlebt, dass Leute ihren E-Mail-Client
auf Dark Mode oder Light Mode eingestellt haben
und ein Background gesetzt wurde per HTML-E-Mail.
Allerdings kein Foreground für die Schrift.
Was dann darauf rausgelaufen ist,
dass der Background mit weißer Schrift,
also schwarzer Background mit weißer Schrift,
bei ihm in der Absendermail vollkommen okay aussah,
aber bei mir, wo ich in Thunderbird ein Light Theme habe,
das nicht so ausgesehen hat,
weil meine Schrift halt schwarz ist.
Und dann war der Hintergrund per HTML auf schwarz gesetzt
und meine Schrift war schwarz.
Und du musstest das komplette E-Mail markieren
oder umgedreht das Gleiche.
Ich hab Dark Mode, das andere Light Mode.
Und...
Das ist halt...
Also HTML-E-Mails ist echt so eines der größten Pepega-Sachen überhaupt.
Deswegen, mein Thunderbird steht nicht auf HTML-E-Mail
und auch nicht auf eingeschränktes HTML.
Mein Thunderbird steht auf Plain Text Only.
Weißer Adler auf weißem Grund, genau.
Die ostfriesische Nationalflagge.
Das kennt wahrscheinlich auch keiner mehr.
Das ist von Otto aus, frag mich nicht, 1985 oder so.
Weiter.
Da könnt ihr dann sehen, ob die E-Mails zum Beispiel...
Selfmade-Eyes, dankeschön.
Es kommt nämlich immer wieder mal vor,
dass Anhänge nicht angezeigt werden.
Etwa, wenn man eine Mail von Apple-Mail sendet
und die dann mit outlook.com im Browser geöffnet wird.
Was man da sonst noch genau wie herauslesen kann,
können Outlook-Anhänge nicht angezeigt werden.
Etwa, wenn man eine Mail von Apple-Mail sendet
und die dann mit outlook.com im Browser geöffnet wird.
Was man da sonst noch genau wie...
Also ganz ehrlich, ich hab, wie gesagt,
ich hab mein Thunderbird ja auch komplett auf Plain Text Only stehen.
Mich fuckt's immer ab, wenn die keinen Text-Fallback drinnen haben
in ihren Mails.
Sondern HTML-Only.
Manchmal ist es notwendig, dass man das umstellt.
Glücklicherweise hat DHL mittlerweile bei Tracking-Codes
auch Text-Fallback, wo man sich den Tracking-Code einfach rauskopieren kann.
Aber ich glaube, Amazon hat auch Text-Fallback.
Mir fällt jetzt kein Beispiel ein,
aber ich bekomm ab und zu mal E-Mails, wo ich reingucken muss
und die haben keinen Text-Fallback und bestehen nur aus HTML.
Das nervt mich immer richtig.
Wie ich herauslesen kann,
könnt ihr in diesem CT-Artikel nachlesen,
oder ihr benutzt ein Header-Analyse-Tool.
In MX-Toolbox kopiert ihr zum Beispiel einfach den Nachrichtenkopf der E-Mail
und bekommt dann mehr Informationen dazu.
Also beispielsweise, ob die E-Mail plausibel sein kann.
Also etwa, ob es ungültige DKIM-Signaturen gibt
oder SMTP-Server, die auf einer Blacklist stehen.
Wenn ihr euch die einzelnen Bereiche aus der Kopfzeile erklären lassen wollt,
dann könnt ihr den Header-Analyse von Gaijin verwenden.
Aber im Zweifelsfall natürlich keine privaten E-Mails in solche Web-Tools.
Das ist ein Five-Head-Tool, um Header zu analysieren.
Zum Überprüfen von Versandbenachrichtigungen oder Werbemails sind die Tools aber gut geeignet.
Die CT-Artikel zum Thema und die beiden Analyse-Tools sind natürlich unten in der Beschreibung.
Ach ja, auch ganz toll.
Ich glaube, man kann sich bei Apple Mail auf dem iPad nicht mal die Header anzeigen lassen, richtig.
Kleine Clients können aber auch ganz schöne Datenschleudern sein.
Das neue Outlook zum Beispiel schickt die IMAP- und SMTP-Zugangsdaten.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte.
Was ein Scheiß, Alter.
Vor allem in den Default-Settings, wo keiner mit rechnet.
Du denkst dir, Alter, ich benutze einen E-Mail-Client und auf einmal synkt das mein Zeug in die Cloud irgendwo hin.
Das fuckt mich so.
Deswegen verwende ich den ganzen Kram nicht.
... und sämtliche E-Mails auch von nicht-Outlook-Com-Mail-Adressen an Microsoft-Server.
Meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei CT konnten beim Anlegen eines IMAP-Kontos mitschreiben,
wie Zielserver Login-Name und Passwort an Microsoft-Server übertragen werden.
Geil, geil.
Da hat TLS geschickt.
Das will ich natürlich.
Meine E-Mail-Credentials im Klartext an Microsoft schicken.
Das will ich.
Das ist genau das, was ich haben will.
Warum wurde das nicht schon immer gemacht?
Das ist doch genau das, was ich will.
Alter, was ein Schwachsinn, Mann.
Vor allem, dass die Default-Settings so kacke sind.
Das heißt, Microsoft kann jetzt jederzeit einen E-Mail-Account durchsuchen.
Ich will ihnen nicht mal böse Absichten unterstellen.
Ich will ihnen nicht mal komplett böse Absichten unterstellen.
Sei es nur zur Auswertung, zu Werbezwecken oder sonst was.
Aber das sind so Dinge.
Und wisst ihr, was ich daran wirklich sehr bedenklich finde mittlerweile?
Also erstens natürlich, dass das gemacht wird.
Aber zweitens, dass es ganz viele Leute nicht interessiert.
Die wissen das und sagen sich dann, ja, ist doch gut.
Dann kann Microsoft wenigstens ordentlich meine E-Mails scannen.
Dann bekomme ich auch pünktlich meine Push-Notification.
Und letztendlich ist dann alles schön gesynct zwischen meinen Geräten.
Ist doch gut, wenn Microsoft das macht.
Dass da eine Mehrzahl der Leute mittlerweile so denken.
Und außerdem, in meinen E-Mails ist doch eh nichts Geheimes drin.
Das macht doch gar nichts.
Das ist eh immer meine Lieblingsantwort.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo beispielsweise Familien-Photos verschickt werden.
Wo die Kinder zufällig im Pool baden.
Und irgendeine AI das als Kinder-Pornos klassifiziert.
Oder irgendwelche Texte ausgewertet werden.
Es gab doch vor ein paar Jahren mal diese Geschichte mit, wo einer auf seine Überweisung geschrieben hat.
Wien-Anflug um 8 Uhr oder sowas.
Wo es dann riesige Probleme gab, weil die gedacht haben, das wäre irgendein Plan für Terroranschläge.
Und solche Geschichten.
In der heutigen Zeit, ganz ehrlich.
Du musst einfach damit rechnen, bei der Menge, die da gescannt wird.
Diese Tools sind nicht perfekt.
Und selbst wenn, die eine Fehlerquote von 0,01% haben.
Bei den Millionen Sachen, die gescannt werden.
Erwischt das früher oder später Leute, die überhaupt nichts verbrochen haben.
Und ja, die Anbieter sagen immer.
Ja, dann gibt es noch eine manuelle Kontrolle.
Ja geil, dann sitzt dann irgendein Peter vom Microsoft Support aus Indien da.
Und guckt sich meine Familien-Photos an oder was auch immer.
Und im Zweifelsfall klassifiziert das auch noch falsch.
Also, das sind so Dinger.
Ganz im Ernst.
Ich finde das birgt enorme Risiken.
Und ich halte auch.
Und jetzt ist Keck-Alu-Time.
Wobei ich das gar nicht mal für sehr viel Keck-Alu mache.
Ich glaube, diese ganzen Einwände.
Dass die Sachen gescannt werden müssen.
Oder Verschlüsselung aufgebrochen werden muss.
Teilweise sogar noch gesetzlich vorgeschrieben und sowas.
Ich glaube ja, dass es der Grund mit Kinderpornos, Rassismus.
Nicht Rassismus, Kinderpornos haben sie immer.
Und terroristischen Anschlägen.
Und Morde aufklären und sowas.
Und Kinderpornos.
Und Kindesentführung und sowas.
Dass das alles nur vorgeschoben ist.
Weil das Punkte sind, wo keiner was dagegen sagen kann.
Weil niemand wird sagen.
Nein, ich will nicht, dass dagegen was unternommen wird.
Wer will das wirklich sagen?
Letztendlich bietet das aber Tür und Tor.
Um damit noch ganz andere Sachen anzustellen.
Jetzt nicht nur von offizieller Stelle.
Sondern eben auch von den Anbietern.
Die dann letztendlich gezieltere Werbung machen können.
Die im Zweifelsfall deine Daten auswerten können.
Für irgendwelche anderen Dinger.
Im Zweifelsfall weiterverkaufen können.
Das sind alles Sachen, die man nicht haben will.
Und das doofe daran ist halt.
Dass das quasi mit in Kauf genommen wird.
Dadurch, dass man eben Vorschub.
Dass man vor.
Ja.
Dass man das so vorschiebt.
Diese Themen Terrorismus, Kinderpornos und sonst was.
Wo keiner was dagegen sagen kann.
Und wenn es dann erstmal da ist.
Dann wird das erweitert.
Jedes Jahr wird es weiter aufgebohrt.
Demnächst wird dann gesagt.
Ja, aber bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Könnten wir doch auch mal reingucken.
Und das ist ja sicherlich nicht das erste Beispiel.
Wo sowas passiert ist.
Wenn man mal historisch guckt.
Ganz viele Sachen.
Wo Datenschutzbedingungen.
Und generell.
Wo solche Sachen gelockert wurden.
Ging das immer weiter.
Immer weiter.
Also mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist.
Und ja.
Ich muss Keck Alu da lassen.
Aber mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist.
Wo sie zur Corona-Zeit gesagt haben.
Man soll Listen.
Man soll sich eintragen.
Was man.
Wann man.
Wo Ansprechpartner im Restaurant gewesen ist.
Und diese Listen werden rein zweckgebunden verwendet.
Zum Nachvollziehen für Corona.
Und da muss ich sagen.
Ich fand das sinnvoll.
Zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Ich hab mir gedacht.
Okay.
Ist doch sinnig.
Wenn rauskommt.
Dass irgendeiner in dem Restaurant Corona hat.
Dass sie mich anrufen können.
Klingt sinnig.
Und ich finde.
Für diesen rein eingeschränkten Verwendungszweck.
War das auch sinnig.
Aber was kam danach.
Drei Wochen später.
Kam die bayerische Polizei um die Ecke.
Und hat gemeint.
Ach so.
Ach.
Wir haben da doch so Daten.
Wer sich wo wie aufgehalten hat.
Können wir die nicht auch bekommen.
Können wir die nicht auch auswerten.
Für Verbrechen.
Ja.
Also.
Es wurde direkt wieder aufgeweicht.
Und das sind halt so Dinger.
Ich denke mir.
Es wird eingeführt.
Mit.
Ja.
Sag mal.
Nach außen hin.
Offensichtlich.
Guten Intentionen.
Ja.
Weil.
Wer will was gegen Terrorismus.
Aufklärung.
Kinderporno.
Wer will dagegen was sagen.
Ja.
Das ist.
Wie sagt man heute.
Richtig.
Und wichtig.
Ja.
Aber.
Wenn das erstmal da ist.
Wird das jedes Mal.
Immer.
Ein kleines Stückchen weiter.
Erweitert.
Und die Anbieter.
Haben wir da.
Wahrscheinlich.
Gar nichts dagegen.
Die können dann sagen.
Hey.
Wir sind ja.
Wir sind ja sogar.
Gesetzlich.
Dazu verpflichtet.
Das Ganze zu scannen.
Und das Ganze zu durchsuchen.
Und bei der Gelegenheit.
Können wir natürlich.
Die Daten.
Die wir ausgewertet haben.
Auch weiter benutzen.
Aber.
Macht euch keine Gedanken.
Das ist alles.
Super anonymisiert.
Und super.
Dezentralisieren.
Und als nächstes kommt dann die ganze Urheberrechtsindustrie und sowas an und sagt, ja, aber guck mal, dann scannt doch bitte auch mal die Cloud, ob da nicht einer illegal MP3s hochgeladen hat oder sowas.
Das geht ja gar nicht. Und nach genug Lobbyarbeit hast du dann auf einmal, dass deine Cloud-Daten irgendwie gescannt werden nach illegalen MP3s, die eventuell gar nicht illegal sind, weil du sie selbst von deiner CD hast.
Und dann wird das immer weiter aufgeweicht und irgendwann gibt es kaum noch Grenzen dafür. Das heißt, ich sehe das enorm skeptisch, diese ganzen indirekten Syncs überall hin.
Per Default-Settings und das zunehmend automatische Auswählen und Durchsuchen von Daten, die eigentlich die Anbieter und keinen außer die Besitzer was angeht.
Ja, also im Prinzip gibt es nur eine Variante dagegen. Wenn man Cloud-Storage verwendet, verschlüsselt hochladen und auch wenn ihr nichts zu verbergen habt.
Ich behaupte nämlich mal, die meisten Leute haben nichts super krass Kriminelles zu verbergen, aber trotzdem Festplatte verschlüsseln, Cloud-Sachen verschlüsseln.
Das ist das Einzige, wie man sich dagegen schützen kann. Und es hat den weiteren Vorteil, wenn ihr eine Festplatte benutzt, die nur verschlüsselt ist und die mal kaputt geht, könnt ihr sie einfach in den Müll schmeißen.
Ihr müsst euch keine Gedanken machen, dass irgendeiner eure privaten Nudes oder was auch immer ihr da habt, irgendwie von der Platte restort.
Also Festplatte per Default, bevor was draufgeschrieben wird, verschlüsseln. Kann ich euch echt nur empfehlen.
Macht das Handling einfacher und ist performant.
Das ist für uns technisch überhaupt kein Problem heutzutage.
So, aber jetzt machen wir mal weiter. Genug gesitetrackt.
...Name und Passwort an Microsoft Server übertragen werden. Zwar TLS geschützt, aber im Tunnel laufen die Daten dann im Klartext zu Microsoft. Das ist jetzt vor allem blöd, wenn man...
Hast du Tipps, wie man sich neue Technologie aneignet? Hast du nicht gestern schon gefragt? Hab ich doch gestern schon was zugesagt.
Du kannst mit dem Hammer auf die HDD hauen, aber guck dir mal an.
Sorry, ich muss jetzt nochmal sagen. Also, du kannst mit dem Hammer auf die Festplatte hauen, dann ist die Festplatte höchstwahrscheinlich kaputt und keiner kann sie mehr auslesen.
Und wenn du ordentlich genug draufgehauen hast, dann kannst du die höchstwahrscheinlich auch mit sehr großem Auswand nicht mehr ordentlich restoren.
Einzelne Bereiche vielleicht noch, aber zusammenhängende Sache eher nicht.
Aber, die Sache, die man sich fragen muss, ist, warum soll ich mich drauf verlassen müssen,
...dass ich mich drauf verlassen muss, dass ich mich drauf verlassen muss, dass ich mich drauf verlassen muss, dass ich mich drauf verlassen muss.
Warum soll ich die Festplatte am Ende ihrer Lebenszeit ordnungsgemäß mit einem Hammer zerstöre, wenn ich das Problem direkt lösen kann, indem ich sie von Anfang an voll verschlüssele?
Wenn du deine Festplatte von Anfang an voll verschlüsselst, dann musst du sie nicht zerstören.
Du musst dir gar keine Gedanken darüber machen.
Die Festplatte ist kaputt, weil der Motor kaputt ist.
Okay, du nimmst sie, schmeißt sie in den Müll, irgendein random Dude kann die rausfischen, den Motor reparieren, anschließend, er kann nichts damit anfangen.
Dann musst du sie nur nicht...
Du kannst sie zusätzlich mit dem Hammer kaputt hauen.
Aber du hast von Anfang an grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen, dass irgendjemand was damit anfangen kann.
Das ist besser, als sie danach kaputt zu machen, wo wahrscheinlich nur keiner was damit anfangen kann, sondern es geht einfach nicht.
Keiner damit was anfangen.
Wenn du es ordentlich gemacht hast.
Das ist der gleiche Grund, warum ich es zum Beispiel doof finde, dass man so viele IOTs...
... eben mit nur einem WLAN-Passwort versorgen kann.
Also die meisten Access-Points, die unterstützen ein WLAN mit einem Passwort.
Fertig.
Daraus ist ja das Wort WLAN-Passwort sogar entstanden.
Das ist ja fast schon ein eigenes Wort mittlerweile.
Aber die allermeisten Access-Points...
Guckt euch...
Die meisten haben eine Fritzbox oder sowas.
Die allermeisten Access-Points unterstützen ein WLAN, also eine SSID, mit einem Passwort.
Und jeder...
... der in dieses WLAN rein will, braucht das gleiche Passwort.
Manche Sachen können noch ein zusätzliches Gäste-WLAN, weil die auch schon gecheckt haben.
Ey, es ist keine gute Idee, wenn man vielleicht für das normale WLAN irgendwelchen Gästen, die nur kurz da sind, das Passwort gibt.
Okay.
Aber jedes IOT-Gerät, was ihr in dieses WLAN hängt, also von der Waage bis zur Glühbirne, bis zum Android-TV-Stick am Fernseher, bis zum Fernseher selbst, bis zu eurem Smart-Trainer.
Alles, was ins WLAN kommt.
Auch ganz kleine Sachen wie Glühbirnen heutzutage, die du per App an- und ausschalten kannst, was auch immer.
Jede kleinste Sache, müsst ihr euch klar sein, das Gerät hat euer WLAN-Passwort.
Das heißt, wenn ihr das Gerät wegschmeißt, irgendjemand das Gerät nimmt und das WLAN-Passwort aus dem Storage ausliest, was bei den meisten Geräten wahrscheinlich gar nicht sonderlich schwierig ist, kann sich in euer WLAN einloggen.
Die Chance, dass das passiert, ist recht gering.
Wahrscheinlich werden sich die meisten Leute nicht für euren Müll und euer WLAN interessieren.
Aber die Frage ist doch, warum muss das überhaupt so sein?
Also sprich, es wäre erstens cool, wenn mehr Geräte WPA Enterprise unterstützen würden.
Und was noch viel geiler wäre, wenn einfach die meisten Access-Point-Hersteller endlich auch mal anfangen und nicht nur die teureren, endlich auch mal anfangen, mehrere Passwörter pro WLAN zu unterstützen.
Das geht ja, das ist ja nichts Neues.
Das funktioniert.
Das unterstützen die meisten Hersteller bloß nicht.
Also bei etwas höherpreisigeren Access-Point-Produkten kannst du mehrere Passwörter für das WLAN vergeben.
Das geht so weit, dass du ein Passwort pro Gerät vergeben kannst.
Ich mache das bei mir im WLAN mittlerweile so, jedes Gerät, was bei mir ins WLAN kommt, auch ins IoT-WLAN, bekommt, ich habe zwar noch ein WLAN-Passwort, ein allgemeingültiges, aber wahrscheinlich schon heute Abend.
Ist das Elo-Tricks?
Ne.
Zeige ich mir auf den ersten Blick so aus.
Jedes Gerät, was bei mir ins WLAN kommt, bekommt ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort.
Kein eigenes WLAN, keine eigene SSID, nein, ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort.
Und wenn ich das Gerät wegschmeiße, dann wird das WLAN-Passwort einfach gelöscht, beziehungsweise halt aus dem Access-Point entfernt.
Und selbst wenn jemand das WLAN-Passwort ausliest, kann er sich damit nicht mehr authentifizieren.
Und das sind so Dinge, wo ich mir denke, warum unterstützen das nicht einfach mehr Geräte?
Das würde Sachen viel, viel sicherer machen.
Exzellent.
So, wir haben das Video immer noch nicht fertig geguckt, wir gucken jetzt endlich fertig.
Oder einem anderen großen US-Mail-Anbieter ist, weil man die eigenen Mails nicht in den USA gespeichert haben möchte.
Microsoft hat sich inzwischen zu der CT-Recherche geäußert und erklärt etwas schwammig, dass die E-Mail-Daten an die eigenen Server gesendet werden, um das Benutzererlebnis zu verbessern.
25.000 Dollar dafür, dass ich Pretty and Rusty reite, so viel Geld können die mir gar nicht bezahlen.
Und zwar immerhin verschlüsselt bei Microsoft gespeichert werden, aber auch nur mit dem Basic-Auth-Verfahren, das für IMAP eigentlich unüblich ist.
Hä? Was soll denn das für eine Antwort sein? Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Hallo Microsoft, also die Frage war, warum synkt ihr ungefragt User-Credentials bei euch in die Cloud?
Und die Antwort ist, Zugangsdaten zu IMAP-Anbietern, deren Server Microsoft mit dem Basic-Auth-Verfahren kontaktiert, speichern wir als Benutzer-Token in verschlüsselter Form in der Mailbox des Anwender.
What?
Das ist keine Antwort auf die Frage, Microsoft!
Und ja, es mag technische Gründe dafür geben, aber die Reaktionen vieler Leute zeigen, dass ihnen gar nicht klar ist, dass Microsoft...
Die Frage ist doch gewesen, warum synkt ihr überhaupt Passwörter zu euch?
...Nutzer-Daten überträgt und Mails auf die eigenen Cloud-Server überträgt.
Das ganze Statement haben wir euch unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt, aber es ist doch alles gelöst, da gibt es doch dieses DE-Mail.
Hat das nicht alle Probleme?
Was anderes fällt mir dazu nicht ein, Alter.
Ich kenne ein paar Leute, die bei DE-Mail...
Wie hieß das andere?
Moment.
E-Post gab es da noch, ne?
Das war die Konkurrenz dazu.
Kann das sein?
E-Post und D-Mail.
Ja.
Probleme der Mail damals gelöst?
Ne.
Also das Thema mit dem...
Rechtssicheren Signieren von E-Mails ist besonders in Deutschland immer wieder gescheitert.
Das Problem bei der DE-Mail war vor allem, dass für die Benutzung der Zertifikate, die man als Porto kaufen musste, ein teures Lesegerät nötig war.
Und auch der neue Ansatz, Zertifikate bei einem sogenannten qualifizierten Vertrauensdienst zu kaufen, um E-Mails rechtssicher unterschreiben zu können, wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht langfristig durchsetzen.
Denn schon das kleinste Paket, das die...
Die meisten heute, weil wir es nicht hinkriegen, die machen Adobe Sign und solche Dinger.
Mittlerweile.
Warum Adobe Sign...
Seriously.
Wisst ihr, was ich bis heute nicht verstehe?
Warum Adobe Sign überhaupt benutzt wird und warum ich nicht einfach mit Paint unterschreiben kann?
Letztendlich ist es auch nicht sicherer.
Ich mal bei Adobe Sign irgendwas drunter.
Oh, okay.
Und das kann ich mit Paint auch machen.
Warum ist das irgendwie sicherer?
Okay, die loggen vielleicht meine IP mit, von wem das unterschrieben wurde und so, aber...
Die Telekom anbietet, kostet 83,19 Euro im Jahr.
Plus Kartenlesegeräte natürlich.
Das Thema E-Mails rechtssicher zu verwenden ist in Deutschland so komplex, dass Gerichte und Anwaltskanzleien ein eigenes System benutzen, namens besonderes elektronisches Anwaltspostfach.
Und...
BEA, besonderes elektronisches Anwaltspostfach.
Das ist ja der deutscheste Name, den ich für ein Produkt in langer Zeit gehört habe.
Und auch im Gesundheitswesen gibt es einfach ein Netz im Netz.
Mit der Telematik-Infrastruktur können Kliniken, Ärzte und Apotheken...
...Patientenakten oder Rezepte abläufig wieder austauschen.
Was es aber leider nicht gibt, ist eine Möglichkeit, für ganz normale Leute an Unternehmen und Behörden rechtssicher E-Mails zu versenden.
Und so wie das aktuell aussieht, wird das leider auch noch eine ganze Weile dauern.
Mein Fazit.
Also, was genau eine E-Mail und das Protokoll da drumrum können muss, war schon vor 40 Jahren recht niedrig angesetzt.
Und klar hat das zu Problemen geführt, aber das war wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum das Ganze so erfolgreich wurde.
Denn während sich Computer und das Internet immer wieder auf die E-Mail-Kanäle drehen, hat sich das auch immer wieder auf die E-Mail-Kanäle drehen lassen.
Und genau deswegen ist die E-Mail auch nicht tot zu kriegen.
Sie ist zu einfach zugänglich und zu etabliert.
Egal ob kurze Nachricht an die Kollegen oder förmliche Mail...
Was guckt ihr die Sorting Labels von B... Wo war das nochmal hier?
Sorting Labels.
Besb...
...RH...
...Az...
...D...
...Eig...
Alles klar, okay.
...immer wieder verändert haben, ist die E-Mail...
...verändert haben, ist die E-Mail...
...eine Konstante in dem ganzen Prozedere geblieben.
Und genau deswegen ist die E-Mail auch nicht tot zu kriegen.
Sie ist zu einfach zugänglich und zu etabliert.
Egal ob kurze Nachricht an die Kollegen oder förmliche Mail an ein Unternehmen.
Mit einer Mail kann man halt fast alles an Textkommunikation machen.
Nur leider ist Mail eben auch unsicher und unzuverlässig, weil keine Sicherheitsmechanismen zwingend vorgeschrieben sind.
E-Mail ist das schlechteste Nachrichtensystem, das es gibt und doch das beste...
E-Mail ist doch das Beste, das wir haben.
Wie ist das bei euch?
Sichert ihr eure Mails noch mit weiteren Kryptografieverfahren ab?
Benutzt ihr überhaupt noch Mail oder nur noch irgendwelche Messenger?
Insgesamt ist weniger Mail geworden, das ist auf jeden Fall.
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und natürlich gerne abonnieren.
Tschüss.
Also Mail ist schon weniger geworden bei mir auch.
Aber beispielsweise die ganzen Sachen, wenn mich irgendjemand anschreibt so nach dem Motto
Ey Max, wir wollen, dass du World of Tanks spielst oder sowas.
Das kommt alles noch an die Business-E-Mail-Adresse, ja.
Keck Business.
So, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Der macht sich so krass.
Okay, Chatge, da müssen wir jetzt durch.
Wir gucken uns von der Gamestar den Test...
Ne, Leute, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Machen wir nicht.
Mich interessiert das Game nicht.
Ich will mich damit eigentlich gar nicht auseinandersetzen.
Das ist zu klein, das C++, das erkennt man als E-Mail nicht mehr.
Guck, wenn man...
Twitch-E-Modes sind tatsächlich echt nicht einfach.
Guck mal, wenn man das hier rauszoomt, so ungefähr so groß ist ein Twitch-E-Mode,
da erkennt man nicht mehr, was am Plus-Plus dahinter ist.
Twitch-E-Modes sind echt eine Kunst für sich.
Kann man irgendwas machen, um seine eigenen E-Mails sicherer zu machen?
Helft mir, was soll ich sagen?
Ich kenne mich mit E-Mails nicht gut aus.
Du kannst auf jeden Fall...
Du kannst auf jeden Fall dein E-Mail-Client auf plaintext-only stellen.
Das macht es für dich sicherer.
Ja.
Also ich benutze nur Thunderbirds seit Jahren.
Ja, und was Verschlüsselung angeht, tja...
Da bin ich ein bisschen planlos.
Ich hab Hunger, ey.
Was ist EIDAS?
Was ist das schon wieder?
EIDAS?
Die EIDAS verordnen...
EIDAS, EIDAS.
...kommt, Logins, aber sicher...
Okay, Chat.
Wer errät, was es bei mir heute zu essen gibt?
Ihr kommt im Leben nicht drauf.
Nudeln mit Lachs, falsch.
Falsch.
Nudeln mit Bolognese, richtig.
Es gibt ja so zwei Varianten.
Wenn es kein Lachs mit Nudeln gibt, gibt es Nudeln mit Bolognese.
Okay.
Lasst uns das schnell nochmal angucken.
Man macht ja immer gute Videos und davon habe ich gar nicht so viel mitgekriegt, was die da treiben.
...und voll digital mit eurem digitalen Ausweis.
Die EU bastelt gerade an einem digitalen Nudeln.
Einem digitalen Wunderwert.
Der ID-Wallet.
Eine Art magischer Geldbörse.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem...
mit PPGA-YouTube-Bewertungen los?
Also ich meine, das liegt am Add-on, aber warum werden hier keine Likes angezeigt?
Die auch irgendwie eure Identitäts- und Gesundheitsdaten sicherer als Omas Sparschwein verwahren soll.
Das klingt alles zu schön, um wahr zu sein, oder?
Ist es auch.
Die Technologie könnte genutzt werden, um jegliche Kommunikation,
online abzufangen und zu verändern.
Na toll.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema waren vorhin, oder?
Von allen Staaten der EU, ohne dass es wirklich Kontrolle oder irgendwelche Limits darüber gibt.
Damit ist das ganze System auch perfekt geeignet für die Anspiel...
Hast du durchgemacht?
Ja, ich bin seit gestern 20 Uhr online.
... der Chat-Kontrolle.
Diese peinlichen Flirtversuche von gestern Nacht mit Manfred von der Abteilung für Sexting zu teilen,
ist nicht gerade die Art von Dreier, die wir uns wünschen.
Warum?
Manfred ist hot as fuck.
... da Bock drauf haben, das sieht man deutlich.
Aber da kommen wir noch dazu.
Die ganze Diskussion um die E-ID, also die elektronische ID,
ist wie immer eine geheime Party, zu der wir alle nicht eingeladen waren.
Alles findet natürlich hinter verschlossenen Türen statt.
Kann ja nicht sein, dass man mitkriegt, was abgeht.
... der letzte Trottel, der vom Türsteher abgewiesen wurde.
Und um das Ganze noch spannender zu machen,
diese EIDAS-Verordnung ist im EU-Trilog am 8. November schon akzeptiert worden.
Und das, obwohl durch einen Leak von drinnen an uns, also die Öffentlichkeit,
alles ans Licht kam und auch der bekritisiert wurde.
Experten vom Chaos Computer Club, Professoren aus der ganzen EU,
Linux Foundation und sogar Mozilla und sogar Google haben die EU gewarnt,
dass da ein, ich zitiere, Security Risk Ahead ist.
Und das alles, damit ich mir online mein neues Auto anmelden kann.
Kommen wir in die Gruppe.
Wir kümmern uns heute um diesen Nebeneffekt der EIDAS-Reform,
den ihr mir mindestens 20 Mal zugeschickt habt
und was da eigentlich für ein Wirbel drum existiert und warum.
Okay, die Hauptbeschwerde des ganzen öffentlichen Briefs.
Naja, nichts weniger als ein trojanisches Pferd,
das es den ganzen Mitgliedsstaaten der EU ermöglichen würde,
mit sogenannten Quacks unsere Daten zu schnappen.
Quacks sind qualifizierte Website-Authentifizierungs-
Unsere Benahmung ist einfach zu geil für alles, Mann.
Kommen wir gleich dazu.
Okay, heißt im Endeffekt, qualifizierte Website-Authentifizierung,
heißt im Endeffekt, man in the middle legal.
So quasi.
Quasi jeder Browser-Hersteller ist gezwungen,
einem EU-CA zu trusten,
dass sie im Zweifelsfall alles mitschneiden können
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also würde ich jetzt reininterpretieren anhand des Namens.
Was es wirklich ist, weiß ich auch nicht.
Website-Authentifizierungs-Zertifikate.
Kommen wir gleich dazu.
Dieser kleine Artikel in dieser EIDAS-Verordnung zwingt...
Das finde ich nicht schlecht, Alter.
Was macht eine Ente auf dem Ruder?
Nat, nat, nat.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Das habe ich wahrscheinlich wieder vergessen bis nächste Woche,
aber den Witz finde ich gut.
... zwingt alle Browser und damit übrigens auch mobile Apps,
alle Zertifikate zu akzeptieren,
die unterhalb dem aktuellen Sicherheitsstandard liegen könnten,
was ungefähr so sicher ist wie ein Schloss,
das mit Kaugummi zusammengehalten wird.
Oder wie die EFF das Ganze beschreibt,
es würde unseren Sicherheitsstandard 12 Jahre in...
Der Iran hat auch schon versucht, eigene Browser...
Das sieht man mal.
Ups.
Das sieht man mal, mit was für tollen Ländern wir uns da vergleichen müssen.
Was ist das?
Das kenne ich.
Das ist doof.
Das ist das Skelett, was an der Decke hängt, gell?
... die Vergangenheit befördern.
Na, großartig.
Dazu schauen wir uns aber zunächst mal an,
wie eigentlich dieser ganze Website-Shit funktioniert.
Was sind denn eigentlich Zertifikate?
Und wieso kann der Staat nicht eigentlich sowieso alles mitlesen,
wenn ich auf Popup nach Germanman fucks the whole Internet suche?
Das gab's da wirklich.
Das gab's da wahrscheinlich wirklich.
Was ist da...
Was macht da eigentlich Axel Voss aktuell?
Axel Voss Twitter.
Gibt's...
Was macht der...
Was macht der Typ noch gerade?
Da ist er.
Hat's ja sehr beliebt gemacht.
Okay, der ist noch aktiv.
Ach ja, die guten alten Zeiten.
Das bräuchte mal ein Update.
Naja.
Also, das Ganze geht so.
Nehmen wir an, ich bin eine Website und du, lieber Zuschauer, willst mich sehen.
Also, meine Website besuchen.
Beispielsweise meine Academy.
Du klopfst an und sagst...
Ich will reden.
Du willst reden?
Ja, ich will reden.
Okay.
Hier ist mein Zertifikat.
Danke.
Ich habe dein Zertifikat erhalten.
Hier ist mein Zertifikat.
Danke.
Ich habe dein Zertifikat erhalten.
Stt.
Prozent.
B86.
Eddb.
Dollar.
Also den Key-Transfer, so wie das RSA auch macht, mal von Hand gemacht, auf einem Papier durchgespielt, wie das funktioniert.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Es ist schon ein paar Jahre her, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich es zumindest verstanden.
Und das war gar nicht so kompliziert.
Da geht es irgendwie darum, eine Seite denkt sich zwei Primzahlen aus, oder nimmt irgendwie zwei Primzahlen, überträgt dann quasi das, was die Zahlen multipliziert, ergebt.
Keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ganz nice, wenn man es mal durchgespielt hat.
Also, weil man versteht ja oftmals nicht, wie es sein kann, dass du privat...
Also.
Ich muss das anders sagen.
Symmetrische Verschlüsselung versteht ja eigentlich jeder.
Du denkst dir ein Passwort aus, du verschlüsselst einen Text mit dem Passwort, überträgst den verschlüsselnden Text.
Das Passwort muss irgendwie dem Empfänger bekannt sein und dann entschlüsselt er es wieder.
Du musst das Passwort aber nicht über den gleichen Weg übertragen, wie die Nachricht.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn du hier mit jemandem zusammensitzt, könnt ihr euch zusammensetzen.
Ein Passwort ausmachen.
Ja, face to face.
Dann fährt der heim und ihr schickt dem einen verschlüsselnden Brief und er kann das entschlüsseln, weil er das Passwort sich gemerkt hat.
So.
Symmetrische Verschlüsselung checken die meisten Leute.
Asynchrone Verschlüsselung ist ein bisschen komplizierter, weil man denkt sich so, ey, wie kann es sein, dass zwei Seiten über einen öffentlichen Kanal, wie das Internet, miteinander verschlüsselt reden können, aber sie den Schlüssel im Vorfeld, die sie dafür brauchen, sie tauschen ja gar nicht den Schlüssel direkt aus,
äh,
wie, wie geht das, dass die quasi öffentlich miteinander reden und trotzdem verschlüsselt Sachen austauschen können, ohne dass jemand, der alles mitschneidet, das lesen kann.
Das, das Funst, das Funst.
Ich hab, ich hab mal RSA mit, mit durchgespielt und meistens läuft's ja dann so, es wird erstmal, ähm, ne, also asynchron ein synchroner Schlüssel ausgetauscht.
Also sprich, du, du, du baust, ähm, du baust quasi die, die, die Verbindung auf.
Und dann tauscht, tauscht du einen synchronen Schlüssel aus darüber, über die verschlüsselte Verbindung, weil synchrone Verschlüsselung halt einfach schneller ist.
Also, ja, was das nicht, wozu dir das nicht hilft, ist festzustellen, dass der andere auch wirklich der ist, für den du ihn hältst.
Das ist wieder was anderes, ja.
Aber, wir, ich muss mir das machen, vielleicht machen wir das mal im Stream.
Wir machen einmal so einen RSA, ich weiß nicht, ob es Handshake heißt oder so.
Können wir mal, können wir mal in einem...
In einem Textdokument machen.
Das ist gar nicht so kompliziert.
Es ist schon ein paar Jahre her, wo ich das gemacht hab.
Es ist, es ist...
Recht, recht easy, wenn man's sich einmal angeguckt hat.
Aber ich, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf auch nicht mehr.
So.
Apropos komische Stimme übrigens.
Ich hab ein Experiment gewagt und das gesamte Hörbuch zu dem Roman 1984...
Chatge...
C... Cringe-Kommentar.
...künstlicher Intelligenz sprechen lassen.
Mit besserer Stimme natürlich.
Für 9 Euro.
Das Hörbuch hat 10 Stunden und ich verlinke es euch in der Endcard.
So, gegen diese Art der Kommunikation gibt es einen relativ einfachen Angriff.
Zumindest, wenn man eben der Staat ist.
Denn unsere Schlüssel, die müssen wir ja, um zu kommunizieren, über Vodafone oder Telekom oder irgendjemand anders drüberlaufen lassen.
Die können wir ja nicht persönlich austauschen.
Und während wir diese Schlüssel austauschen, können die die ja einfach ersetzen und ihre einfügen.
Und am Ende kommunizieren wir immer so, dass eigentlich der Staat bzw. der Provider immer alles mitlesen kann.
Also Passwörter...
Kreditkarten...
Suchanfragen...
Damit das nicht passiert, gibt es vertrauenswürdige Anbieter von solchen Zertifikaten.
Die packen dann ihre Unterschrift darunter, dass eben das da gerade wirklich das Zertifikat von Pornhub, der Bootstrap Academy ist.
Und denen vertrauen wir.
Das heißt, die Zertifikate von diesen Anbietern, die sind bei uns auf dem Rechner und auf dem Handy in...
Ja, außer man ist Komodo und lässt sich das Root-Zertifikat klauen.
...Styling...
Solche Anbieter sind also, sagen wir mal, unfassbar kritisch, denn die sind technisch gesehen in der Lage, diese ganzen Zertifikate immer dann auszutauschen, wenn sie eben gerade Lust und Laune haben.
Wir alle müssen also den Anbietern vertrauen.
Damit das alles also nicht passiert, haben die meistens einfach...
Glücklicherweise, glücklicherweise gibt es dafür Let's Encrypt mittlerweile.
...Kommunikationsweg, sprich Vodafone oder Telekom, geben solche Sachen nicht raus.
Und sie werden extrem streng...
...kontrolliert.
Das ist eigentlich sowas wie Gewaltenteilung im Internet.
So, und gibt man nun diese Macht zurück in staatliche Hände, dann ist das eine Art Freifahrtschein, um Verschlüsselungen für den Staat einfach, wann immer sie wollen, aufzubrechen.
Und damit natürlich auch in der Lage zu sein, Nachrichten zu lesen, Online-Profile über uns zu erstellen mit all den Daten, die sie haben.
Alle Daten einfach nach Belieben...
Sollte das kommen...
...bin ich der Erste, der einen Firefox-Fork verwendet, mit den Zertifikaten wieder entfernt.
Also mit dem Trust-Store wieder entfernt.
...einzusammeln...
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass Firefox da mitmachen wird.
Es sei denn, es ist gesetzlich dazu gezwungen.
Und selbst dann ist man die Frage, ob man die dazu, wie weit man die dazu zwingen kann.
Es kam mir schon öfters mal vor, dass Browser quasi gegen solche Versuche vorgegangen sind und Zertifikate blacklisted haben sogar.
Die für solche Zwecke benutzt werden sollten.
Und damit eigene komische KI-Projekte durchzuführen zum Beispiel.
Die Liste ist eigentlich hier recht endlos.
So.
Und das alles wird mit diesen Quacks gemacht.
Quacks sind eigentlich Websites, die am Ende eben eines dieser speziellen EU-Zertifikate haben.
Das sind Zertifikate, wie immer, nur eben herausgegeben von einem Anbieter von der EU.
Wichtig ist aber, Websites sind nicht verpflichtet, Quacks zu werden.
Es könnte also alles so bleiben, wie es ist, ob du hier bist und nicht.
Das Problem kommt in anderen Facetten.
Quacks könnten eine Art Vertrauen symbolisieren.
Nur eine Quack sollte besucht werden.
Alles andere ist ungefiltert, ungeprüft und der ganze böse anarchische Teil des Internets...
...in dem halt dann die EU nicht mitlesen kann.
...in dem noch Regel 34 praktiziert wird.
Das kann Websites natürlich unter Druck setzen, so ein Zertifikat zu bekommen.
Und wenn die dann so ein Zertifikat haben, dann kann der Staat wieder theoretisch alles mitlesen.
Und damit besteht natürlich...
Lass mich raten. Die Begründung ist die gleiche wie immer.
Morde aufklären, Kinderpornos aufklären, Terrorismus aufklären und sowas.
Das sind immer die gleichen Sachen, die da als Begründung kommen.
...das Quacks plötzlich doch verf...
Und als nächstes, und als nächstes kommen dann die Copyright-Leute und sagen,
Lass uns doch auch mal gucken.
...pflichtend werden, weil die EU-Regeln zum Beispiel ausgeweitet werden.
Gibt es eine Regelung, dann wird die ja häufig einfach erweitert und auf Dinge angepasst.
Ein Beispiel wäre hier die Chat-Kontrolle.
Dabei geht es darum, dass eine KI über unsere privaten Chats drüberlaufen soll...
...und da mal reinguckt, ob da vielleicht illegale Materialien drin wären.
Und das umzusetzen wäre mit Quacks so unfassbar einfach.
Man müsste einfach jede Chat-Applikation in der EU verpflichten, eine Quack zu werden.
Fertig. Schon kann der Staat alles mitlesen und staatlich prüfen.
Außerdem muss diese Funktion, Quacks zu akzeptieren, in jeden Browser eingebaut werden.
Das wurde so beschlossen.
Browser meint damit wie gesagt auch Android oder IOS.
Wie gesagt, ich werde als erstes auf dem Browser einen Fork verwenden...
...auf dem Desktop einen Fork verwenden, wo das nicht drin ist.
Ja. Mobile wird in der Tat enorm schwierig.
Weil da hast du weniger Einfluss drauf, was du verwendest.
Bleibt dir im Endeffekt ja nur noch Android mit im Custom Browser.
Unter IOS kannst du es vergessen. Da ist alles Safari.
Und wenn die das einbauen, ist es überall eingebaut.
Wie gesagt, es gibt ja kein Chrome und Firefox für IOS.
Apps, die mit dem Internet kommunizieren, nutzen nämlich auch Zertifikate.
Der große Problempunkt dabei ist, jeder Browser muss diese Quacks akzeptieren.
Auch wenn die einen Sicherheitsstandard von 19 Millionen haben.
Kein Browser darf bei einer Quack Nein sagen.
Damit kann man effektiv als Quack die Sicherheit seines Nutzers einfach herabstufen auf 1995.
Alles in allem ist das also im besten Fall eine dumme Richtlinie...
...die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen in Browsern und Systemen außer Kraft setzt...
...die es zu guten Gründen gibt.
Im schlechtesten Fall aber kann das ganze System von Haggern...
...von Haggern, genau...
...von Hackern oder auch Staaten massiv missbraucht werden.
Die Haggermans.
Die es vielleicht nicht ganz so genau nehmen mit der Demokratie.
Es könnte also problemlos erweitert werden.
Und da tut sich die Frage auf...
Was zum Geier sucht so eine Verordnung eigentlich in der EIDAS-Reform?
EIDAS bedeutet Digitale Ausweis.
Hier geht's um Web...
Moment.
Ich weiß gar nicht wofür es steht.
Das hat nichts miteinander zu tun.
Denn in der Ankündigung und den öffentlichen Dokumenten...
...war auch nie die Rede von irgendwelchen Website-Zertifikaten.
Sagen wir, es gibt ein gewisses Misstrauen...
...warum mit so einer Verordnung so immens intransparent umgegangen wird.
Ja, warum wohl?
Dazu kommt sogar noch, dass die Instanz, die all diese Verwaltung...
Firefox für iOS gibt es als App, aber unter der Haube ist es trotzdem Safari.
Apple erlaubt keine andere Browser-Engine als Safari.
Unter iOS.
...die Zertifikate für Quacks ausstellt.
Das ist das ETSI.
Nein, nicht die von der TV-Werbung, auf der man urheberrechtlich problematische Dinge zuhauf findet.
Mit I am Ende.
Das Europäische Institut für Telekommunikationsnormen, kurz ETSI...
...hat eine gewisse Vergangenheit und auch Gegenwart...
Von denen habe ich noch nie was gehört.
...mit teilweise sehr problematischen Sicherheitsstandards.
2009 beispielsweise wollte man den Sicherheitsstandard TLS 1.3...
...den wir übrigens alle für Verschlüsselung mit Websites nutzen...
...einfach absetzen für ETS.
Das wurde von Experten damals zerlegt, denn...
Okay, wie...
Was für eine ultra dämliche Idee, Mann.
Wir haben hier was, was millionenfach getestet...
...verwendet wird, getestet ist, sich etabliert hat...
...ersetzen wir durch irgendwas von uns, wo keiner eine Ahnung hat, ob es richtig funktioniert...
...was eventuell übelst unsicher wird...
...was eventuell übelst unsicher ist, weil es doch keiner Praxiserfahrung mit hat...
...und wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal irgendwie sich Leute, die Ahnung damit haben, angeguckt haben.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den Wettbewerb, wo es um AES ging damals.
Also AES hieß ja nicht schon immer AES.
AES ist ja der Standardname im Endeffekt.
Der Advanced Encryption Standard.
Allerdings was es nicht heißt ist...
Also AES ist nicht der Algorithmus in dem Sinn.
Also für AES wurde ein Algorithmus gesucht über einen Wettbewerb am Anfang.
Und ursprünglich...
Also der jetzt unter AES bekannt war, war ursprünglich der.
Das ist das, was der den Wettbewerb gewonnen hat, vermutlich.
Und die Telekom hat bei diesem Wettbewerb...
...das wissen auch gar nicht so viele...
...die Telekom hat bei diesem Wettbewerb mitgemacht damals...
...mit einem Algorithmus, der sich Magenta nannte.
Die sind nicht weit gekommen.
After the presentation of the cipher at the first AES conference...
...several cryptographers immediately...
...also nachdem die den vorgestellt haben...
...haben einige Crypto-Experten sofort...
...Fehler, also Anfälligkeiten gefunden in diesem Algorithmus.
Und seitdem waren die halt wieder weg.
So.
...did not advance...
...beyond the first round.
Cryptographic weakness were discovered...
...and it was found to be one of the slower ciphers.
Also das war...
...das war nicht nur schlecht...
...das war auch noch langsam.
Also Telekom hat es wieder vollgerissen bei dem...
...Wettbewerb hier.
Übrigens, ich finde das eine mega Idee.
Und das sollten eigentlich alle so machen...
...dass es, wenn so ein neuer Standard gesucht wird...
...dass man einen Wettbewerb macht.
Finde ich eine super Sache.
Fördert letztendlich kreative Ansätze...
...kreative Ideen, Wettbewerb...
...und am Ende kommt das Beste dabei raus.
War das zu Zeiten vor der asymmetrischen Verschlüsselung?
Nee.
Asymmetrische Verschlüsselung und symmetrisch...
...du brauchst beides.
Du brauchst beides.
Ich meine, auch weil der Browser asymmetrisch verschlüsselt...
...verschlüsselt er nicht alles asymmetrisch.
Zum Beispiel der...
...in der Regel wird das so gemacht...
...es wird asymmetrisch...
...verschlüsselt...
...und zwar ein...
...Schlüssel...
...um synchron damit nachher zu verschlüsseln.
Weil asymmetrisch einfach langsamer ist.
Also du baust quasi, sagen wir mal...
...so eine asymmetrische Verbindung auf.
Asymmetrisch verschlüsselte Verbindung auf.
Darüber...
...tauscht du dann einen Schlüssel aus...
...und danach verschlüsselst du...
...mit diesem Schlüssel symmetrisch, weil es schneller ist.
Ja, also...
...im Prinzip...
...ist das beides.
Ähm...
...brauchst beides.
Telekom hat einen Cloud-Ausfall.
Gibt es echt jemanden, der Magenta Cloud verwendet?
Da musste...
...da musste man einen Microsoft-Trainer...
...kecken über mich.
Ich habe ihn einfach mal demonstrativ gefragt.
Er hat erzählt, Microsoft Cloud...
...also Fazit von ihm war halt...
...Microsoft Cloud...
...beste, beste Sache ever.
Aber man kann Microsoft Cloud auch supertoll...
...mit anderen Anbietern...
...verwenden.
Man kann beispielsweise Services von anderen Anbietern...
...gut integrieren, manchmal auch...
...Microsoft Sachen exportieren...
...zu anderen Anbietern.
Und da habe ich den damals gefragt...
...ob denn auch Magenta Cloud supportet wird.
Da hat er nur gekeckt...
...und hat gar nichts großartig drauf gesagt.
Also...
...wahrscheinlich wollte er mir sagen...
...wer verwendet sowas denn?
Okay, guck mal weiter.
...ETS entfernt ein wichtiges...
...Sicherheitsfeature aus dem...
...Telekom.
Ich würde lieber die Lidl Cloud verwenden.
Die haben wenigstens...
...gut, die Telekom hat auch Erfahrung.
Wir müssen die Telekom gar nicht mal schlechter machen...
...als sie sind.
Die Telekom hat teilweise jetzt mal...
...Real Talk und keine Werbung für die Telekom.
Die Telekom hat schon durchaus fähige Leute.
Ja, dass es ab und zu die ein oder anderen Fails gibt.
Aber die Telekom hat schon wirklich schlaue Leute.
Ich habe letztens zum Beispiel mit...
...zwei Blockchain-Experten telefoniert...
...von der Telekom.
Einer hatte Ahnung, der andere war der Teamleiter.
Also im Endeffekt, einer hatte Ahnung...
...der andere war aus Marketing-Gründen dabei.
Und die haben uns dann ein bisschen...
...erzählt, wie das intern bei der Telekom...
...so läuft, wie die da ihre...
...Blockchain-Infrastruktur betreiben.
Das ist schon ziemlich...
...bleeding-edge neues Zeug, was die machen.
Und das kann auch nicht jeder.
Ich muss sagen, die haben durchaus fähige Leute.
Leider sieht man halt immer...
...nur die Fails.
Ist die Magenta Cloud Open Telekom Cloud?
Kann sein. Früher hieß das mal Magenta Cloud.
Nee.
Scheint doch nicht.
Aber ich glaube OpenStack ist das...
...das Telekom Zeug.
...Standard von TLS...
...namens Forward Secrecy.
Das kennt ihr vielleicht sogar.
All das ist eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig.
Forward Secrecy war doch die Geschichte mit...
...ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr ganz sicher...
...ob das das ist...
...was ich meine.
Forward Secrecy ist doch die Geschichte mit...
...dass wenn ich...
...heute...
...war das das...
...wenn ich heute was mitschneide...
...dass es dann...
...auch wenn...
Nee, nee, das war was anderes.
Dann weiß ich es nicht.
Nee, oder?
Dass ich dann mit den Sachen von morgen nichts mehr...
...ich krieg es nicht mehr richtig zusammen, was das war.
Keine Ahnung.
...Secrecy. Das kennt ihr vielleicht sogar.
All das ist eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig.
Aber der Fakt, dass ein bedeutendes Feature...
...einfach entfernt wurde, das keinerlei Nachteile bietet...
...der schon heute für Schutz sorgt...
...das ist ein gewisser...
...Beigeschmack. Da hatte ich übrigens auch schon...
...ein Video dazu gemacht.
Und auch im Standard für Polizei- und...
...Militärradios, der natürlich auch verschlüsselt...
...sein sollte, wurde...
...buchstäblich eine Hintertür gefunden.
Der Standard wurde 1995...
...entwickelt und...
...befindet sich in allen möglichen...
...Geräten von Motorola über Airbus.
Allerdings wurde...
...dieser Standard nie der Öffentlichkeit...
...zugänglich gemacht und so wurde erst...
...diesen Sommer, also fast...
...30 Jahre später, eine...
...Sicherheitslücke entdeckt.
Wäre das Ganze öffentlich gewesen, dann hätten...
...da mehrere Leute drüber gucken können und das hätte...
...wahrscheinlich nicht so lange gedauert.
Da gibt es ja zig Beispiele für.
Eines meiner Lieblings-Security...
...Sachen, wo ich in den letzten Jahren...
...über immer mal wieder ein bisschen verfolgt habe...
...ist die ganze Management-Sachen, die...
...bei Intel-Mainboards und Intel...
...Enterprise-Sachen eingebaut sind. Da gibt es doch...
...diese Intel...
...Management-Engine-Geschichten...
...und dieses Ding hatte schon...
...immer regelmäßig...
...irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken.
Aber Intel sagt da halt nichts zu. Du hast...
...keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert. Du hast keine Ahnung, was es macht.
Es kommen bloß regelmäßig...
...Sicherheitslücken raus, wo Leute wieder...
...geschafft haben, diese komische Intel-Management-Engine...
...zu exploiten.
Und auch der Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmus...
...aus den 1990ern...
...für mobile Telefone wurde...
...vom Etsy entwickelt und...
...nicht veröffentlicht.
2021, also in diesem Fall...
...über 30 Jahre später...
...haben Forscher der Ruhr-Universität...
...Bochum eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden...
...die, ich zitiere...
...sehr unwahrscheinlich durch...
...einen Unfall erstellt wurde.
Absichtlich eingebaut.
Und übrigens, es gibt eine...
...bordwörtliche Arbeitsgruppe des Etsy...
...die einen Standard entwickelt, der...
...sich mit rechtmäßiger Überwachung...
...und Aufbewahrung von Daten für...
...Strafverfolgung beschäftigt. Also zusammengefasst...
...Browser werden zu schwächeren...
...Sicherheitsstandards gezwungen.
Von einer Institution, die eine...
...gewisse Geschichte mit staatlicher...
...Überwachung hat und das...
...möglichst unauffällig in einer Verordnung...
...wo es eigentlich um unseren...
...digitalen Ausweis gehen sollte.
Mhm, ist klar.
Vermutlich möchte man einfach mit anderen Staaten...
...gleichziehen, die dieses absolut demokratische...
...Werkzeug schon längst nutzen. Iran...
...z.B. praktiziert das Ganze aktiv.
Oder China. Oder Kasachstan.
Aber lasst uns noch...
...einen ganz kurzen Blick auf den eigentlichen Ausweis...
...werfen, denn auch dabei gibt es...
...einiges an Kritik.
In dem Artikel 6 der EIDAS-Reform.
Aktuell sieht...
...der Verordnungsentwurf vor, dass...
...relying Parties aus der...
...ID-Wallet Daten verknüpfen...
...oder nachverfolgen können.
Sprich nutze ich...
Da fragt man sich halt, welche Parties das dann sind.
...die Bootstrap Academy und eine...
...Krankenkasse und melde mich dort jeweils an...
...dann können die Daten von diesen...
...relying Parties...
...zusammengeführt werden. Und zu diesen...
...relying Parties zählen eben auch...
...die Regierungen. Ach ja.
Dadurch wird Profiling natürlich ziemlich gut möglich...
...teilt sogar, wenn die Inhaber...
...sprich ich, dem ganzen über ihren Ausweis...
...nicht mal zugestimmt haben.
Es steht zwar viel drin bezüglich...
...strengem Schutz vor Tracking und Profiling...
...aber leider ist dieser Schutz laut...
...dieser Verordnung halt einfach...
...keine Pflicht, sondern er ist komplett...
...optional. Und da die ID-Wallet...
...einfach Identitätsdaten, Finanzdaten...
...und sogar Gesundheitsdaten...
...enthalten soll für Millionen Bürger...
...wäre das vielleicht schon...
...ganz sinnvoll, wenn es nicht optional ist.
Denn wie wir mittlerweile wissen...
...wird gesammelt, was möglich ist.
Technisch und rechtlich.
Das finde ich auch.
Der serverseitige Code der E-ID-App...
...muss nicht quelloffen sein. Das ist auch immer...
...so ein Ding, dass das nicht nur...
...so geheim...
...hinter den Bühnen irgendwie...
...immer alles ausgeheckt wird...
...aber dass du noch nicht mal...
...wenn du eh mehr oder weniger quasi...
...gezwungen wirst, den Scheiß zu verwenden...
...noch nicht mal in der Lage bist...
...zu sagen, okay...
...was...
...läuft da eigentlich?
So könnte man zum Beispiel auch feststellen, okay...
...der Scheiß ist richtig stümperhaft...
...und schlecht implementiert...
...hat Sicherheitslücken...
...deswegen wollen sie es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil, eines muss man ja mal festhalten...
...viele Leute werfen dann immer ein, so nach dem Motto...
...ja, aber sowas sicherheitskritisches...
...kann doch nicht quelloffen sein.
Und da sage ich als Antwort, doch!
Gerade was sicherheitskritisches...
...muss quelloffen sein. Der Witz ist...
...ja, Sicherheit bedeutet ja...
...in dem Fall, du musst wissen...
...können oder du darfst wissen...
...wie etwas funktioniert. Bis ins Detail.
Aber dieses Wissen alleine...
...darf dir trotzdem nicht helfen...
...das auszuhebeln.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn davon.
Machen wir mal...
...ein ganz...
...ein ganz einfaches Beispiel, ja.
Also, ich...
...generiere...
...eine random Zahl...
...oder nee, ich generiere...
...eine Zahl und ich...
...teile die...
...mit Modulo und nehme den Rest.
Ja, also ich mache keine Ahnung.
Ich generiere mir eine Zahl...
...und sage mal 7...
...oder 10 oder so und sage dann...
...Mod 3 und nehme den Rest.
Und ich verschicke...
...ich verschicke nur den Rest.
Da könnte man jetzt ja sagen, okay...
...ich kann das mitlesen...
...und ich weiß, wie der Algorithmus...
...funktioniert. Jetzt weiß ich...
...was du ursprünglich für eine Zahl generiert hast.
Nö, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß, dass...
...irgendjemand eine Zahl generiert hat...
...und davon...
...Rest genommen hat, aber...
...ich habe keine Ahnung, was der wirklich...
...gemacht hat, obwohl ich weiß...
...wie der Algorithmus funktioniert und ich kann...
...Plaintext lesen, was der übertragen hat.
Vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber ich glaube...
...ihr wisst, was ich meine. Also, in dem Fall...
...darfst du wissen, wie das funktioniert...
...und du darfst auch alle Daten mitlesen...
...und du weißt trotzdem nicht...
...die geheime Zahl im Endeffekt.
Ich meine, es ist relativ easy auszuprobieren dann...
...bei kleinen Zahlen.
Und so muss das sein.
Du musst wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Guckt euch Linux an.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass jeder bei Linux...
...durchblickt. Es gibt wahrscheinlich nur ein paar...
...handvoll Leute auf der Welt, die da wirklich durchblicken.
Aber...
...trotzdem, dass der Linux-Körnel an sich...
...und alle...
...Standard-Tools...
...offen sind, gibt es doch...
...verhältnismäßig wenig Sicherheitslücken.
Guckt euch mal an.
Sudo zum Beispiel. Und Sudo hat eine...
...Historie mit Sicherheitslücken. Da gab es immer mal...
...wieder welche. Aber sogar Sudo.
Also quasi ein Kommando, wo ich...
...mit meinem User als Admin...
...mich einloggen kann.
Wer es nicht kennt, ich zeige es euch...
...einfach. So, hier bin ich mein User.
Ich bin Max.
Max darf aber beispielsweise an Systemdateien...
...nix machen. Also sage ich...
...dann muss ich ein Passwort eingeben...
...und dann bin ich root. Root ist quasi...
...Administrator unter Linux.
So, und...
...trotzdem, dass diese Tools...
...alle Open Source sind...
...kann nicht jeder dahergelaufene...
...Hints und Kunst einfach root werden auf...
...meinem Server. Weil...
...das Tool soweit sicher ist...
...dass es eben das macht...
...was es soll. Und obwohl du weißt...
...wie es programmiert wurde, trotzdem nicht...
...einfach jetzt ausnutzen kannst. Also das ist...
...sicher. Dadurch...
...unter anderem, weil es so viele Leute benutzen...
...so viele Leute sich den Source Code angucken...
...können. Ich habe absichtlich sudo genommen...
...weil bei sudo sieht man, dass selbstverständlich...
...auch Open Source Software...
...nicht davor sicher ist, Sicherheitslücken...
...zu haben. Es gab...
...nämlich erst vor 1-2 Jahren...
...diese...diese...
...Geschichte hier mit... warte mal...
...so, ok, ich bin wieder da.
Ähm...
...ja, also, ich habe absichtlich sudo genommen, weil...
...bei sudo gab es letztens eine größere Sicherheitslücke...
...da konntest du relativ einfach...
...gut werden. Aber es ist, denke ich, ein gutes...
...Beispiel für gewesen, dass man sieht...
...ok, selbst wenn man weiß, wie die Sachen...
...funktionieren, darf man nicht...
...das trotzdem umgehen...
...können.
...technisch unrechtlich.
Experten sehen auch im Konzept...
...Ausweis im Internet insgesamt...
...ein Problem. Es ist ein leichtes zu sagen...
...Websites für Erwachsene...
...Spieler ab 18, da müssen wir uns...
...ausweisen. Das wäre natürlich erstmal einfach...
...nicht angenehm, aber...
...vielleicht noch verständlich.
Aber wo hören wir auf? Was, wenn YouTube...
...auf einmal sich entscheidet, Bots eindämmen...
...zu wollen und deshalb einfach basierend...
...auf der ID Menschen...
...von der Plattform aussperrt? Wenn sie...
...ein schlechtes Kommentar zum Beispiel geschrieben haben...
...dazu brauchen sie dann...
...auch eine ID. Was, wenn...
...Online-Spiele dann einfach sagen, ey...
...wir wollen uns nicht mit dem...
...Korea! Ist es nicht sogar in Südkorea...
...so? Also Südkorea, nicht...
...Nordkorea. Ähm, Südkorea...
...dass wenn du...
...dich bei einem MMO...
...meldest, du das nur mit Ausweis-ID...
...darfst? Und du...
...im Zweifelsfall, wenn du cheatest, gebannt...
...wirst mit Ausweis-ID und sowas?
...Schutz von Minderjährigen rumschlagen...
...also, Ausweis her, unser Game...
...ist ab 18. Nicht nur wird es...
...immer normaler, es würde auch immer...
...häufiger werden und immer mehr Websites hätten...
...unsere Identität, die natürlich...
...auch verknüpft werden kann.
Ja. Zumal die meisten...
...Websites es halt einfach nicht brauchen.
...haben wir noch nicht mal gesprochen. Ausweisdaten,
...Finanzdaten und Gesundheitsdaten...
...auf einer einzigen Plattform...
...für Millionen Bürger und dann sogar noch...
...die Möglichkeit, einfach eine Blanko...
...Überwachung zu machen. Selbst...
...wenn wir maximales Vertrauen in unseren Staat...
...haben, das sind Daten, mit denen man...
...richtig viel Unfug machen kann.
Ich überlasse das einfach mal eurer Kreativität.
EDV Forensik, kommt genau richtig...
...zu dem Video gerade. Danke für den...
...anstellen könnte. Jeder...
...bösartige Hacker denkt sich bei solchen...
...Daten...
Das ist ein Schmacko-Fatz.
Und ganz ehrlich...
...Deutschland ist ein technisches...
...Entwicklungsland. Uns anzumaßen, dass...
...wir es gar mit staatlichen Hackern aus...
Ist das nicht der Typ, der immer Zigarren...
...testet? Von dem habe ich auch schon...
...ein paar Videos geguckt. China aufnehmen...
...könnten... Ich rauche nicht, by the way.
...einfach lächerliche Hybris.
Ich finde die Videos mega...
...entspannend.
Von dem habe ich auch schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Irgendwelche Zigarren-Tests.
Was verdient... Jetzt gucken wir das nächste Mal.
Chatge, ich hab Hunger.
Ich esse jetzt was. Nudel...
...Nudel mit Tomatensauce.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Abend wieder...
...zu einer weiteren Runde...
...Placingly Fast Written in Rust.
Muss ich mal gucken...
...wie ich das nenne.
Okay, Moment. Chat.
Ich erkenne gar nicht, was man da sieht.
Was sieht man da?
Man sieht...
...C++?
Ach, auf einem Keck!
Nee, das ist auch noch nicht so das.
Wie gesagt, Twitch Emotes...
...sind echt so ein Ding...
...für sich.
Ich bin der Sache auf jeden Fall positiv...
...aufgeschlossen, wenn wir ein schönes...
...C++...
...Keck-Emote finden...
...dann nehmen wir das.
Alles klar, bis dann. Wir sehen uns.
See you.